THE BUDGET THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO
WILL COME TO ORDER A GOOD
MORNING- AS WE CONTINUED TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RESTS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC IN ITS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH THE IN PERSON
EVENT TELECONFERENCE BURGESS
PATIENT FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARBORS THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW STATES
PARTICIPATE. OUR NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR ONCE AGAIN THAT'S
844-291-6364 IN THE ACT SIX ACT
SIX CODE IS. 1-511-401-4111 FOUR
ZERO I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING I STILL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THE PRESIDENT ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED- SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH. A QUORUM AND TAKE THE
NECESSARY ACTIONS THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE. WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR THOSE FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONE CERTAIN COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I'M I S.
IT EVERY TIME THAT YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE THAT USED TO RAISE THE
HAND FEATURE. IN THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME THAT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT A MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
TO SPEAK R. I. T. PERSON THAT
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOUR DAD ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE. YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING RECALL FRIENDS
A LOT. IN USE TELECOM SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUAL WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY- THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE HEARD. AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED NOW WE HAVE SOME
CHANGES ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WE HAVE TO. ISSUES
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE
DEPARTMENT OF OUR CONSERVATION
THE OIL WELL ABANDONMENT AND
REMEDIATION HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE CALENDAR AND- ISSUE
NUMBER NINE THE AIR RESOURCE
BOARD- AND THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT THE RACIAL EQUITY
PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER NINE. HAS
BEEN REMOVED WE WILL DEAL WITH
THOSE NEXT WEEK- AND WITH THAT
SAID WE WILL WAIT FOR HI MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN IN AND OUT-
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO LET'S
GO. ON OUR AGENDA TO OUR FIRST
DISCUSSION ISSUE WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN. AND. THAT THE-
IT'S ADDRESSING EXTREME HEAT AND
WE HAVE A- GAGGLE OF STATE
AGENCIES THERE I UNDERSTAND. THE. OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
WILL LEAD OFF THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING- PLEASE
PROCEED. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR-
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY NAME
IS AMANDA HANSEN AND I SERVE AS
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE AT THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. YES I'M ON THE
PLEASE PROCEED THE PRESENTATION
. I DO I ACTUALLY I BELIEVE THAT
MY COLLEAGUE NEW ATARI KEY- IT'S
GOING TO JUST INTRODUCE HERSELF
BRIEFLY IF SHE'S ABLE TO. NO ONE
TARA GOOD MORNING LOW GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE I'M DOING
PARK HE'D DEFINITELY DIRECTOR
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AND- GET JOIN HERE TO
PRESENT ON THIS. TOMORROW THANKS
THANK YOU AT. FOR THE INVITATION
TO PRESENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
EXTREME HEAT SATISFIED. I'M
GOING TO PROVIDE THE VERY BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE IMPACT OF
EXTREME HEAT IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FUNDING PROPOSAL%
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN AND
THEN YOU ENTIRE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
SENATE SIDE PROPOSAL ITSELF. SO
BEST AVAILABLE CLIMATE SCIENCE
PROJECTS THAT EXTREME HEAT WILL
IMPACT EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE. AND POSE RISKS TO EVERY
REGION AND EVERY SECTOR. EXTREME
HE THREATENS CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES. NATURAL SYSTEMS AND
OUR ECONOMY AND ALSO PERHAPS IT
ALSO POSES PROFOUNDLY
DISPROPORTIONATE CONSEQUENCES.
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
US. LAST YEAR WE EXPERIENCED THE
HOTTEST SUMMER ON RECORD. WITH
DEATH VALLEY SETTING AND
FORTUNATE WORLD RECORD FOR THE
HOTTEST MEASURE TEMPERATURE IN
HISTORY. IN ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DEGREES IN JULY. AND
FRESNO SAW OVER SIXTY DAYS ABOVE
ONE HUNDRED DEGREES. THE DAILY
MAXIMUM AVERAGE TEMPERATURE
WHICH IS AN INDICATOR IT'S AN
INDICATOR OF EXTREME TEMPERATURE
SHIPS IS EXPECTED TO RISE
BETWEEN FOUR POINT FOUR AND FIVE
POINT EIGHT DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
BY TWENTY FIFTY AND FIVE POINT
SIX AND EIGHT POINT EIGHT
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT. BY TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN WAS DEVELOPED AS
PART OF THE STATE'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UPDATE TO
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION STRATEGY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED FOR AN
UPDATED. INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING EXTREME HEAT. IT
OUTLINES CALIFORNIA'S ALL OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
MITIGATING THE HEALTH ECONOMIC
CULTURAL ECOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL
IMPACTS OF INCREASING
TEMPERATURES AND HEATWAVES. THE
ACTIONS IN THE PLANS WERE
DEVELOPED AND REFINED BY OVER
FIFTY STATE ENTITIES AND THROUGH
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT OVER THE
COURSE OF LAST YEAR. THAT PUBLIC
INPUT REALLY HELPED US ORGANIZE
THE EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN
AROUND FOR. ACTION TRACKED
IDENTIFIED BY OUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH FOLKS ACROSS THE STATE IS
VERY IMPORTANT OR- BEING AREAS
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR STATE ACTION
AND ENGAGEMENT THE FIRST IS
BUILDING PUBLIC AWARENESS THE
NOTIFICATION TO INCREASE
UNDERSTANDING OF HEAT STRESS
AND- BETTER PREPARED FOR EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS. THE SECOND IS
STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY SERVICES
IN RESPONSE TO INCREASE
COMMUNITY CAPACITY REDUCE
ECONOMIC RISKS AND INCREASED
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. THE THIRD AREA OF
FOCUS IS INCREASING THE
RESILIENCE OF OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENT TO REDUCE HEAT RESTS
IN THE TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
BUILDING SECTORS. SIX SORRY OKAY
THANKS THE BOARD IN THE FOURTH
AND FINAL ACTION KILLER IS
UTILIZING NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
TO CORACLE COMMUNITIES AND BUILD
THE RESILIENCE OF OUR NATURAL
SYSTEMS TO INCREASING
TEMPERATURES. SO THE EXTREMELY
ACTION PLAN IDENTIFIES SIX AREAS
OF NEAR TERM FOCUS WHICH ARE
REFLECTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE EXTREME
HE SAYS I PROPOSAL THAT YOU
ENTIRE IS GOING TO. WALK THROUGH
NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF MODERN AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE I KNEW WHEN PARKEY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE RESEARCH SO THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION SET ASIDE
EXTREME HEAT SATISFIED INCLUDE
PROGRAMS FROM SEVEN STATES AND
CITIES ACROSS THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE ABOUT DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. AND THE PROPOSED
FUNDING PROGRAMS ARE ORGANIZED
ACROSS FOUR CATEGORIES THE FIRST
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION TO ACCELERATE READINESS
AND PROTECTION OF COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY EXTREME HEAT
INCLUDING THROUGH COOLING
SCHOOLS SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS AND EXPANDING
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS THIS
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION THE
CALIFORNIA TO CALL SCHOOLS
WORKING WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND OTHERS TO FOCUS THE URBAN
AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY PROGRAM
GRANT FUNDS TOWARDS THE GREENING
OF SCHOOL OF SCHOOL YARDS. THIS
CATEGORY ALSO INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION TO THE
STRATEGIC PROGRAMS OFFICE
SUPPORT COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTERS BY PROVIDING GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY SEEKING TO BUILD OR
UPGRADE EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
SUPPORT PROGRAMS ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING COMMUNITY. LEVEL SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE SECOND CABIN
INCLUDING THIS- EXTREMELY
SATISFIED INCLUDES FORTY THREE
ONE MILLION TO PROTECT BOTH
POPULATIONS AND GOES FROM SIX
HEAT PRESS. THIS FUNDING TO
ENHANCE PROTECTIONS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS INCLUDING
WORKERS IN HIGH RISK INDUSTRIES
AND INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS AND
LICENSED CARE FACILITIES. I'M
RESPONDING TWENTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION IS PROPOSED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
HELLO OSHA AND WILL BUILD UPON
AND EXPAND ITS TARGETED OUTREACH
AND ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM HEAT
RELATED ILLNESSES. THIS WILL BE
COUPLED WITH TARGETED
ENFORCEMENT BEFORE AND DURING
PERIODS OF HIGH REST. ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS SECTION IS ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH BRANCH TO
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO EMPLOYERS TO
INFORM THEM ABOUT EXTREME HEAT
RESTS IN INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
SETTINGS. ALSO IS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION COMPOSED OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
TO PROVIDE OUTREACH OVERSIGHT
AND EDUCATION AND TRAINING ABOUT
EXTREME HEAT AND IT'S A FACT. TO
SURVEYORS OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND LAST IN THIS
CATEGORY IS EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE TARGETED
INFORMATION TO PREVENT HEAT
RELATED ILLNESSES BIRDS LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL AND CHILD CARE
FACILITIES THAT LACK THE
RESOURCES TO ADEQUATELY. PREVENT
IMPACTS. ALSO THIS. GOING TO THE
FINAL TO BRING I'M NOT AND
WORKING LANDS SYSTEMS AND
BIODIVERSITY THERE IS A PROPOSED
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. TO SUPPORT SMALL
UNDERSERVED FARMERS AND LARGE
DISADVANTAGED URBAN CENTERS
THROUGH INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND OUTREACH. THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN PILOT
PROJECTS INITIATED BY COLLECTION
CENTERS RENDERERS AM COMPOSTERS
TO HANDLE UNEXPECTED ANIMAL
MORTALITY DUE TO EXTREME HEAT AS
WELL AS PROVIDE ORIGIN
INSPECTION SERVICES. TO ENSURE
THAT PASSED THAT MAKE PRIVATE
UNDER INCREASED HE CONDITIONS
ARE EXCLUDED FROM ENTERING THE
STATE. MOVING TO THE THIRD
CATEGORY THERE'S A PROPOSED
TWENTY MILLION INCREASE PUBLIC
AWARENESS TO REDUCE STRESS MOST
BY A STRING HE- THIS FUNDING
PROPOSAL BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
REQUEST TWENTY MILLION TO
DELIVER THIS PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN. WITH KEY COMPONENTS
INCLUDE ENGAGING A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL INCLUDE DEVELOPING
TAILORED AWARENESS MATERIALS AND
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MEDIA SPECIALIZING IN IN
LANGUAGE AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CONTENT. AND FINALLY
THE CATEGORY IN THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDE SEVENTEEN MILLION TO
EXPAND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
BUILD A CLIMATE SMART WORKFORCE
YOU CAN OPERATE UNDER INTO
DRASTIC STREET. WITH FUNDING TO
GO TOWARDS THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
WHICH REQUEST SEVENTEEN MILLION
FOR DEVELOP AND EXPAND MORE HIGH
ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS TO
ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT. AND THE
MORTAL PARTNER WITH RELEVANT
STATE AGENCIES TO EXPAND ITS
CURRENT FOCAL PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED TECHNOLOGIES
INNOVATIONS AND INDUSTRIES THAT
ADDRESS AND MITIGATE EXTREME
HEAT. WELL CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND CREATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN WORKFORCE FOR
THESE EMERGING ROLES. WITH THAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE- TO BE HERE AND HAVING TO
TAKE ANY QUESTION THANK YOU.
OKAY IS. AN THE WE HAVE A LOT OF
A AGENTS- DEPARTMENT.
REGULATIONS PUBLIC HEALTH. CAL
OUR- PARTNER BAG ANYBODY ELSE
HAS SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT 2%
OR IF YOU'RE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
L. A. L. IS THIS A ROOF WE
PURGING. DOZENS OF AGENCIES AND
ENTITIES HAVE PUT TOGETHER THIS
PLAN HOWEVER- WE HAVE A QUESTION
ON THE COHESIVENESS OF THE
STRATEGY. ONCE YOU GO AHEAD-
MISTER. THE YOU MISTER AND HE'S
WARNING GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
CHAIR- EUNICE ROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
TODAY WE HAVE SOME INITIAL
COMMENTS WITH REGARDS TO THAT
PROPOSED PACKAGE- SO OVERALL WE
FIND THAT THE PACKAGE IS
COMPRISED OF A DIVERSE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES- INTENDED TO ADDRESS
EXTREME HE S. YEARS RANGING CM
DIRECT INTERVENTIONS FOR HEAT
RELIEF. TO EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH FOR EXTREME HEAT
AWARENESS- HOWEVER WHILE SOME OF
THESE IN THE INDIVIDUAL
ACTIVITIES- MAY HAVE MERIT IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THESE PROPOSALS
ADDRESS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CONCERNS ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
EXTREME HEAT AND WHETHER THIS
COMBINATION OF PROPOSALS. IS THE
MOST STRATEGIC WAY TO ADDRESS
SUCH PRIORITIES. THIS PACKAGE IS
INTENDED TO ALIGN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- RECENTLY
FINALIZED EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN WHICH DOES INCLUDE- SEVERAL
GOALS. BUT BECAUSE THE AND PLAN
LACKS A CLEAR STRATEGY AND
MEASURABLE GOALS IT'S DIFFICULT
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
PROPOSED PACKAGE IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE MOST
PRESSING CONCERNS RELATED TO
EXTREME HEAT. AND IN ADDITION-
WE FIND THAT- IF THE FUNDS A
WIDE RANGE OF ACTIVITIES THE
PACKAGE IS LIMITED IN SOME
IMPORTANT AREAS SUCH AS- DIRECT
HEAT REDUCTION INTERVENTIONS AND
RESEARCH. SO FIRST WITH RESPECT
TO ADD DIRECT HEAT REDUCTION
INTERVENTIONS THE PACKAGE IS NOT
INCLUDE SOME CRITICAL TYPES OF
BUILDING LEVEL INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS AIR CONDITIONING
INSTALLATIONS AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RETROFITS IN PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE SPEND MOST OF THEIR
DAYS SUCH AS- HOMES WORKPLACES
AND SCHOOLS AND THESE TYPES OF
INTERVENTIONS COULD PROVIDE
DIRECT. DIRECT RELIEF FROM
EXTREME HEAT ESPECIALLY FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO MODIFY THEIR
SURROUNDINGS WITH ADDITIONAL
ANSWERS WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE. AND SECOND- I AM.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR RESEARCH
MIGHT BE WORN TED- JUST BECAUSE
MUCH A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
REMAINS ABOUT WHICH POLICY
INTERVENTIONS ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO REDUCE THE
NEGATIVE AT IMPACTS OF EXTREME
HEAT. FURTHER RESEARCH WHICH
COULD INCLUDE A PILOT PROGRAMS
AND EVALUATIONS- COULD HELP
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION SUCH AS
WHICH ACTIVITIES ARE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ADDRESS
EXTREMELY AND WHICH PROGRAMS ARE
BEST SUITED AT SERVING THE MOST
VULNERABLE. THE LEGISLATURE MAY
ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER WHICH
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES ARE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR A ONE TIE
FUNDING. SOME TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES ARE- JUST MORE
NATURALLY PROGRAM FOR A ONE TIME
FUNDING THAN OTHERS SUCH AS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS PILOT
PROGRAMS- AS WELL AS RESEARCH
BECAUSE THE BENEFITS OF THESE
ACTIVITIES REMAIN AFTER THE
FUNDING ENDS. SO FOR EXAMPLE ALL
THE FUNDING FOR- TO GREENING
SCHOOLYARDS AND STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
COULD CONTINUE BENEFITING FROM
MORE TREES AND SHADE AND THEIR
SCHOOLYARDS IN TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDORS- WELL BEYOND THE
FUNDING PERIOD. IN CONTRAST I'M
USING ONE TIME FUNDS FOR LIMITED
TERM STAFFING AND SERVICES MIGHT
BE LESS EFFECTIVE. BECAUSE THEY
WOULD ONLY PROVIDE BENEFITS
DURING THE FUNDING PERIOD FO
INSTANCE- THE PROPOSED
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES UNDER CAL
OSHA LIKELY WOULD NEED TO BE
CONDUCTED ON THE ONGOING BASIS
TO BE YOUR MOST EFFECTIVE. I'M
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER THIS THE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT OR STYLE
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE PACKAGE
IS CONSIDERED EXCLUDABLE FROM
SOUTH BY ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION IS
SUBJECT TO THE LIMIT SO GIVEN.
THAT STYLE WILL CONTINUE TO
CONSTRAIN THE STATE'S BUDGET
OPTIONS THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
SHIFTING MORE FUNDING TO
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
EXCLUDABLE AFRISAM. AM WE ALSO
NOTE THAT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES SOME OTHER
EXTREME HEAT I AM RELATED
PROPOSALS OUTSIDE OF THIS
PACKAGE SO FOR EXAMPLE. AND THE
BUDGET INCLUDES AN TEN MILLION
FOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
REAL TIME DATA AND THE HELL
HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
WHICH INCLUDES INCLUDING EXTREME
HERE- AND IN ADDITION- THERE IS
THAT FIVE MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED LAST YEAR IN LAST
YEAR'S I CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE FOR EXTREME HE
ACTIVITIES AS WELL SO. THE
LEGISLATURE MADE I JUST WANT TO
CONSIDER THE FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR ALL RELEVANT HERE RELATED
ACTIVITIES- THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET AND BUT THIS YEAR AND
LAST YEAR TO ENSURE. ITS
APPROACH OF STRATEGIC
COMPREHENSIVE AND NOT
DUPLICATIVE. AND FINALLY- THE
PROPOSED PACKAGE DOES NOT
INCLUDE A PLAN THAT TO REPORT ON
THE OUTCOMES THAT ARE ACHIEVED
THAT THE FUNDING. AND WE FIND
THAT THE ROBUST REPORTING WENT
TO HELP THE LEGISLATURE CONDUCT
PROPER OVERSIGHT AND ALSO HELP.
INFORM FUTURE POLICY AND FUNDING
DECISIONS REGARDING EXTREME HEAT
STRATEGIES. AND SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS SO
FROM HELP. HELP ME OUT ON THE
BALANCE BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
EXTREME HEAT- CHALLENGE AND A
LOT OF THIS THERE'S A CHOICES
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
POLICY OF DO WE- FOCUS ON THE
CAUSES OF. EXTREME HEAT AND
TRYING TO REDUCE THOSE OR WE
DEALING WITH THE SYMPTOMS- WITH
EXTREME HEAT- THAT WE HAVE OUT
POINT OUT ON THAT THE COOLING
COMMUNITIES IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THE SCHOOL YARD URBAN FORESTRY.
WHILE IT WILL TAKE A WHILE FOR
THE TREES TO GROW WOULD CREATE
AND- A LONG TERM. INFRASTRUCTURE
CHANGES- AND THE NATURAL WAY TO.
DEAL WITH THE HEATING VERSUS
PUTTING AN AIR CONDITIONER IN A
HOUSE WHILE IT MAY HELP OUT THE
PERSON IMMEDIATELY IS SORT OF
THIS WE'RE JUST DEALING WITH THE
SYMPTOMS STILL GONNA GET HOT
OUTSIDE YOU THE AREA OUTSIDE IS
HOT. DO YOU UNBALANCE THE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE. IS MORE ON
REACTION TO THE SYMPTOMS AND
THERE IS TO THE HELPING WITH THE
GENERAL COOLING. IS THAT YOUR
OBSERVATION ARE. HE SAID THIS AT
CLEAR WHAT THE ACTION IS- I
THINK SO I MEAN I THINK YOU KNOW
THERE THERE DEFINITELY NEEDS TO
BE A BALANCE ALSO BETWEEN KIND
AND NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS LIKE
YOU'RE REFERENCING KIND OF TREES
AND- KIND OF MORE OF THAT KIND
OF YEAH MORE TREES TO PROVIDE
MORE SHADE AND- COMMITTEE
SETTINGS SUCH AS SCHOOLS BIRTH
IS ALSO- AND- MORE THINGS THE
MORE LIKE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
RETROFITS OR AIR CONDITIONING
UNITS. THAT COULD COOL- AND
BUILDINGS SO AND I THINK TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT A CERTAIN LEVEL
OF EXTREME HE IS INEVITABLE SO I
DO THINK SOME OF THE SHORT TERM
INTERVENTIONS TO DIRECTLY
PROVIDE RELIEF IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I'M BUT AS YOU SAID IT
IT DOES HAVE TO KIND OF BALANCE
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER CLIMATE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES THAT. THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALSO BEEN ADDED
CONSIDERING AND OTHER OTHER
PACKAGES AND UP AFTER AT THE
OTHER SO THE REST SO MY READ OF
THE- WITH THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WITH THE RESILIENCY
CENTERS IS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT LIBRARIES.
COMMUNITY CENTERS. CAN FAIRS
PLACES WERE WERE PEOPLE
CONGREGATE AND THEN PUTTING IN
AIR CONDITIONING AND OR PUTTING
IN. SOMETHING THAT WOULD CREATE
A- A COOLER ENVIRONMENT IS
SERVICE- THIS IS NECESSARILY
GOING INTO INDIVIDUAL HOMES IN
GIVING SOMEBODY AN AT AN AIR
CONDITIONING UNIT IS THAT YOUR
READ ON IT IS IT IS THAT THEY
WOULD BE YOU KNOW WE TRY TO GET
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK
FOR THIS HUNDRED AND SEVENTY.
MILLION DOLLARS IN THESE AREAS
THAT ARE GONNA BE AFFECTED AND
THAT. IT'S IT IT'S AN EXISTING.
CENTER THAT'S COULD BE TURNED
INTO A COOLING CENTER I GUESS I
SHOULD SAY. OR YOU DO NOT READ
IT THAT WAY. BEFORE I GET TO
THAT. THE GROWTH COUNCIL ON OPR
ON IT. YES ANSWERED
DEMONSTRATION MAY WANT TO BUY
ANSWER THIS QUESTION AS WELL BY
YES MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT AS
THE FUNDING COULD BE USED
TOWARDS SOME BUILDING LEVEL
IMPROVEMENTS WHICH COULD INCLUDE
AND SOME COOLING OR EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES AND- DAD'S AT. SO IT
COULD YOU KNOW. AND BENEFIT MORE
INDIVIDUALS THAN I GUESS AT
ADDRESSING AT A PRIVATE
RESIDENCE LEVEL. FINANCE OF YOUR
RESOURCES'S ANYBODY WANT TICKET
CLARIFICATION OR A- AUGMENTATION
OF WHAT THE PLAN IS. YEAH MRS
NEWMAN PARTIES FROM OPR I WILL-
JUST OFFER A QUICK- RESPONSE
HERE AND THEN- I WILL TURN IT
OVER O MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IF THEY
HAVE ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE
RESILIENCE CENTERS COMPONENT OF
YOUR QUESTION I'M IN FRONT OF
THEIR- BEFORE I DO THOUGH I
WANTED TO I'M- GOING TO YOU KNOW
TO YOUR QUESTION SENATOR AROUND
KIND OF THE RELATIONSHIP OF
INVESTMENT AND DISTRIBUTION OF
INVESTMENTS LOOKING AT REDUCING.
THE IMPACTS AND THEN- IN
ADDITION YOU KNOW COMPLIMENTED
INVESTMENTS ON ADDRESSING THE
SYMPTOMS DID TO YOUR POINT I
WOULD ALSO POINT TO THE FUNDING
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CLIMATE
BUDGET THAT DOES AT- ON AUGMENT
SOME OF THOSE REDUCING THE
IMMEDIATE IMPACTS INCLUDING
FUNDING TO THE RESPONSES
AGENCIES FOR. URBAN AND
COMMUNITY FORESTRY INTERPRETIVE
READING PROGRAMS AND THEN THE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR A NEW
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE IN EXTREME
HEAT PROGRAM THAT ILL BE AT OPR
THAT WILL BE AT THE STANDING UP
IN THIS COMING BUDGET YEAR THAT
WILL ALSO DEDICATE RESOURCES TO
SOME OF THOSE HEAT EDUCATION
ACTIVITIES THAT YOU MENTIONED SO
JUST. NOTING THAT. WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THREE HUNDRED
MILLION SEVENTY. THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL. ON PROPOSAL ARE
OFFENDING RATHER FROM LAST YEAR
ARE IN COMPLIMENTS YOU THE FUNNY
FOR QUITE SOME BESIDE. IN OUR
ITSELF I'D RATHER SO I'M MAKING
A POINT THEN I WILL SEE MY CAR
FROM STRAY PETERSBURG COUNCIL
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL POINT ON THE
WRIST. CENTERS OKAY AND THEN
WE'LL GET TO- ALEJO. YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH IN RETURN THANK YOU
SENATORS I JUST WANTED TO VERY
QUICKLY- EMPHASIZE THAT THE
UPGRADES MADE TO RESILIENCE
CENTERS BUT ALSO INCLUDE. AND
ENERGY RETROFITS AND OTHER
NECESSARY MEASURES TO HAVE KIND
OF. LOW EMISSIONS OR- SOMEONE
MEDICATION MEASURES EMBEDDED
INTO IT SO THAT THE CENTERS
WOULDN'T BE. I'M DEVELOPING
NECESSARILY ADDITIONAL EMISSIONS
SO THAT WILL ABSOLUTELY WE'D BE
PART OF THE PROGRAM DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL SO YOU
YOU YOU YOU GOT AN OLD WRECK
BUILDING AND YOU'RE GOING TO.
POP OUT THE SINGLE PANE WINDOWS
YOU GO TO INSULATE THE SIDES YOU
COULD PUT IN A I HAD. M. HM
SYSTEM N. N. AND SOME CHAIRS FOR
PEOPLE TO COME IN WHEN IT'S
EXTREME HEAT I MEAN IT'S AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION BUT BUT THAT
TYPE OF BUILDING THAT'S ENERGY
INEFFICIENCY THAT DOESN'T
CORRECT CREATE A COOLING CENTER
THAT'S- CONTRA GO TO NOW ALIVE
OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE. SO IT'S
ABSOLUTELY SO MY SELLERS AT THE
ALEJO. MORNING RETAILERS WITH
THE L. OUT JUST ONE
CONSIDERATION TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION AND AS YOU ALL ARE
THINKING ABOUT PUTTING TOGETHER
A PACKAGE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
FACING TWO CHALLENGES AROUND THE
HEAT. AB ROUND ONE IS THESE
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS WHERE IT'S
REALLY REALLY HOT FOR A COUPLE
OF DAYS AND WE NEED PLACES FOR
PEOPLE TO GO TO BE SAFE. BUT
THERE'S ALSO AND IN PARTICULAR
IN CERTAIN AREAS OF THE STATE
WILL WE'RE GONNA JUST HAVE
SUSTAINED DAYS OF MUCH HIGHER
TEMPERATURES WHERE IT'S NOT KIND
OF A ONE OR TWO OR THREE DAY
ISSUE IT'S MORE OF A LIKE. ALSO
KIND OF ISSUE WHERE. THEY MAY
NOT BE REASONABLE TO EXPECT THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GO SOMEPLACE
ELSE OUT OF THEIR HOME FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME WHEN THEY HAVE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT WHEN THEY HAVE
PETS WHEN YOU KNOW THAT AS AS
PART OF THEIR KIND OF EVERY DAY
LIFE. THEY'RE GOING TO D. CAMP
SOMEWHERE ELSE THAT HAS- A
COOLER TEMPERATURE AND SO I
THINK THAT'S PART OF THE BALLOTS
TO THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW SPENDING
PACKAGES HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THESE SORT OF. AB IT DIDN'T KIND
OF DUAL CHALLENGES ONE ISN'T
REALLY EXTREME HEAT WHERE YOU
MAY SAY OKAY WE GOT IT WE GOT A
MOBILE PEOPLE AND GET THEM
SOMEWHERE SAFE FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. VERSES ALSO
THINKING ABOUT AREAS OF THE
STATE WHERE- IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY A LOT HARDER FOR
SUSTAINED PERIODS OF TIME AND
HOW DO WE ENSURE WORKERS ARE
SAFE AND THAT KIND OF LONGER
TERM AREA RESIDENTS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS- SO REALLY
AS YOU THINK ABOUT YOUR
RESPONSES. KEEPING IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE- KIND OF THESE TWO
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS. THAT BOTH
ARE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. OF MISS COACH OF. OUR
VON. LEE WITH STREET STRATEGIC
GROWTH CAL- WHAT DO YOU SAY ISIS
ED AN INCIDENT OF EXTREME HEAT
OR SUSTAIN SUCH- HE'D. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING EXECUTAR THIS
DROUGHT COUNCIL ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS TO REMEMBER
ABOUT THAT COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTER SAYS THE WAY THAT THEIR
STRUCTURE IS BOLD WAS THE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE IN EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS SO AS AS A COOLING
CENTERS BUT MENTION BUT ALSO AS
A PLACE ON AN ONGOING BASIS FOR
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON
RESILIENCY PLANNING TO GAIN
ACCESS AWARENESS OF ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
OFFERED THE MAY BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM WITH THEIR INDIVIDUAL.
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO PORT ST KEEP
CONDITIONS ABSOLUTELY THESE ARE
BOTH A LONGER TERM EXTREME DAY
USAGE BUT THEN ALSO EIGHT ALWAYS
PEOPLE TO HELP BUILD THE SUPPORT
STRUCTURE OF SOCIETY APRICUS
WILL BE ABLE TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSEHOLD LEVEL AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL BE ABLE TO
PREPARE THE STATE EXTREME
CONDITIONS AND I PRESUME THAT'S
PART OF THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU WON OVER TWO
YEARS FOR THE PUBLIC AWARENESS.
CAMPAIGN. INCREASING PUBLIC
AWARENESS. SO I WOULD I WOULD
ASK YOU TARA TO COMMENT ON. ALSO
THEN. BUT THE- THE ALLEN ARE.
THE AB ONE AND SEVENTY MILLION
WITH RESILIENCY CENTER. BUILT
INTO STRUCTURES ARE THE TACTIC
ASSISTANCE THE DS. TO MAKE THESE
RESULTS SAID ALSO FOR COMMUNITY
IN SUPPORT SO IT'S NOT A FIELD
IF YOU BUILD IT THEY WILL COME.
GOING TO OUT TO ME SURE THEY
KNOW IT'S THEIR- YES MISS. A
MISS KEY DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THERE. YEAH I WOULD JUST- ON THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS- FUNDING
PROPOSED TO COME TO- PR YOU KNOW
THAT IS VERY MUCH IN RESPONSE TO
THE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC INPUT
FOLDER IMPORT WE GOT WHILE
DEVELOPING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN WAS
REALLY THAT THE RECOGNITION THAT
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
NEEDS SUPPORT IN BUILDING.
AWARENESS AROUND THE IMPACTS OF
EXTREME HEAT BEFORE THEY HAPPEN
AND THEN ALSO MAKING SURE
THEY'RE THE RIGHT STRUCTURES AND
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS WITHIN
COMMUNITIES NGUYEN EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS- DO OCCUR AND SO THAT
FUNDING IS REALLY TARGETED THE
TWENTY MILLION PROPOSALS REALLY
TARGETED AT SUPPORTING BROAD
COMMUNITY AWARENESS AROUND
PUBLIC AWARENESS RATHER AROUND
EXTREME HEAT. BEFORE AND DURING
EVENTS. I HAVE A QUESTION THE
GOING TO GET TO MISS THE CENTER
STARTED SECOND BUT A QUESTION
FOR MR AGUILERA- WE'VE GOT
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEMS SINGLE PANE WINDOWS.
INSULATING BILL MAKING. ENERGY
EFFICIENT- BUILDINGS NOTHING
SPECIAL WHAT IS SPECIAL WHY
WOULD WE NEED TO DO ADDITIONAL
HIGH ROAD PARTNERSHIP TRAINING
IN THIS PROPOSAL NOT ELSEWHERE
IN THE BUDGET BUT WHY IN THIS
PROPOSAL FOR WHAT WOULD SEEM TO
ME. ORDINARY IMPROVEMENTS. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- RAFEAL AGAIN
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD APPRECIATE OPPORTUNITY
HERE- SO WITH MY OUR PROGRAM THE
HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
WHAT WE DO IS WE SET UP
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT. AND WORKFORCE
PROFESSIONALS AND BASICALLY TRY
AND LINK TO ME LABOR DEMANDS
THAT ARE ON THAT AND LOOK FOR
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENHANCE- EQUITY
JOB ACCESS LINK PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AND SO
I MEAN WHAT I THINK OUR VALUE
ADD HERE IS THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
GONNA LOOK AT CLIMATE CHANGE
FROM A MITIGATION PERSPECTIVE
THE JOBS THAT ARE CREATED- BUT
NOW AN ADAPTATION AND EXTREME
HEAT. FRAMEWORK PERSPECTIVE AND
ALL THE POTENTIAL JOBS THAT. YOU
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW WILL
GENERATE NEW OPPORTUNITIES SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BASICALLY
ATTEMPT TO DO HERE IS A BRIDGE
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY ALL THE
AGENCIES HERE. TODAY THERE ARE
STRATEGIC PLANNING THEIR
ADAPTATION DOCUMENTS AND OUR
WORKFORCE STRATEGY AND MEETING
THAT LABOR DEMANDS WHICH AS YOU
KNOW- AS YOU CAN SEE IN MY
BACKGROUND EVERYTHING THAT- YOU
KNOW IT'S GONNA TAKE TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE FACT. IS
THAT I REQUIRE A REAL PERSON TO
INSTALL UPGRADE MAINTAINED-
THOSE THOSE ARE YOU KNOW HARDEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE BEST
THING WE CAN DO IS LEVERAGE THE
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS TO CREATE
THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENTS- ENHANCED UP QUALITY
GOALS AND FOR EXAMPLE CREATE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU KNOW LEAD TO
PIPELINES. FOR ON JOB ACCESS AND
JOB QUALITY- IN THOSE TRADES.
AND MANY OF THOSE TRADES ARE
TRADE BECAUSE- LIKE TRISH- LATE
HOURS AND MAKE LINK I GUESS MY
POINT WAS IS THAT WE HAVE LOTS
OF MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GENERICALLY WE'VE GOT TO GET
PLUMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GET. A
PEOPLE TRAINED TO DO IT I'M
ASKING WHY THERE'S ADDITIONAL
MONEY IN THIS BECAUSE IF WE
TRAINED IN ANOTHER SECTION OF
THE BUDGET FOR WINDOW
INSTALLERS. THEY DON'T NEED
SPECIAL. HOW TO BUILD. A CLIMATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO PUT IN
THE WINDOW AT ONE OF THE CENTERS
AND BAKERSFIELD BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY KNOW HOW TO PUT THE
WINDOW AND THERE'S NOT THAT MUCH
I'M JUST ASKING. IS THERE
SOMETHING SOME. SKILL SET THAT I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT WOULD BE
PARTICULAR FOR ANY OF THESE
EDUCATION THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
OR THE YOU KNOW. YEAH WELL YOU
KNOW THESE ARE THE ISSUES THAT
WE ANTICIPATE- DISCUSSING WITH
OUR SKINNER A- PARTNERS AND THEY
WILL BE MARRIED AND MANY OF PART
IN BETWEEN. BECAUSE WHAT WE DO
IS WE TAKE A REGIONAL APPROACH
AND THE SECTOR APPROACH THERE
ARE INDUSTRIES THAT WE HAVE NOT
THOUGHT OF PERHAPS- THE URBAN
GREENING AND LANDSCAPING- YOU
KNOW THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WILL CERTAINLY COME ABOUT. YOU
KNOW ELECTRIFICATION SMART GRID
BATTERY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES
BEING INTEGRATED AND- YOU KNOW
BRINGING TO BEAR THE MOST. NO
AVAILABLE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGIES TO ADAPT TO
THOSE THINGS ISRAELI I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA WAY YEAH NO I GET
THAT WE HAVE LOTS OF MONEY AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GENERICALLY AND I'M JUST SIR
TRYING TO SEPARATE THIS IS THAT
THIS IS THIS IS. NOT
PARTICULARLY A BUILDING OR OF
MAKING ENERGY EFFICIENT
RESILIENCY CENTER DOES NOT AT
LEAST IN ITS AT LEAST WHAT'S
PRESENTED TO US I DON'T SEE ANY
PARTICULAR NEW. SKILLS THAT
SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE TO. BUT
DEVELOP THEY JUST BUILT REGULAR
BUILDING A REGULAR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BUILDING THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH EXTREME HEAT
SET ASIDE PROGRAM THIS IS JUST
I'M JUST MORE OPENING. GIVE YOU
SOME CONCERNS AS WE DO HERE TO
PUBLIC AT THE HEARING. ARE AMONG
THE HANSON WITH THE- DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE. I SEE
RECOGNIZE ISSUE. THANK YOU I
JUST- MAYBE TODAY SIR DIRECTLY
RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION I
THINK. THAT YOU KNOW OUR VISION
IS THAT IN MANY CASES IT IS TRUE
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE CAREERS
AND ADDS. EXISTING WORKFORCE ALL
THE PROGRAMS WERE PERHAPS
INTEGRATION OF EXTREME HEAT
MAKES SENSE. THERE ARE OTHER
INDUSTRIES AND CAREERS WHERE THE
WORK THAT'S GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO DELIVER ON EXTREME
HEAT IS NOT AS IT IS NOT AN
EXISTING PROGRAM OR IS NOT AN
EXISTING INDUSTRY OF FOCUS- SO
YOU KNOW MAINTAINING ROADS WITH
THE MATERIALS THAT ARE REQUIRED
OR YOU KNOW. LESS HEAT
ABSORBING- I'M I'M IN WORLD SO
FORGIVE ME BUT THAT KIND OF
MAINTENANCE THAT IS HEAT
RESISTANT SAME THING WITH YOU
KNOW CONSTRUCTION WITH THESE
KIND OF NEW BUILDING MATERIALS.
ADAM THE YOU KNOW PASSIVE.
PASSIVE BUILDING CERTIFICATION.
I AND THERE'S JUST SORT OF AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
GROWING IN THE FUTURE TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE I THINK IF I MAY I'D
LIKE TO ALSO JUST GO BACK TO THE
QUESTION OF SORT OF IS THIS A
BALANCED PACKAGE I DO UNDERSTAND
IT'S HARD TO SEE ALL THE PIECES.
TOGETHER JUST BECAUSE YU CAN
SEE THERE ISN'T SOMEONE BLASTERS
BUDGET THERE'S SOME IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET IN
JANUARY AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
FUNDING ARE SET ASIDE HERE BUT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SORT OF POINT
OUT WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS THAT
IS THAT THE PROPOSED IN JANUARY
BUDGET. FOR PROTECTING- HAVE LOW-INCOME AT COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE
IN OUR POPULATIONS THAT LIVE IN
OLDER BUILDINGS THAT ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT
WE HAVE FUNDING FOR LIVE WITH TO
DO A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT KIND OF
UPGRADE IN WITH THE INTENTION OF
IN ENSURING THAT EXTREME HEAT IS
CONSIDERED WE HAVE FUNDING FOR
THE HEALTH DATA SYSTEM THAT HAS
HAS COME UP HERE WE HAVE FUNDING
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS
WE'VE JUST DISCUSSED BUT ALSO
FUNDING FOR WORKER PROTECTIONS.
AND ENFORCEMENT AND EDUCATION
OUT WE ALSO HAVE THE YOU KNOW
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS OPR
IS EXTREME HEAT PROGRAM AND THEN
A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
TO AND FOR THAT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS IN THIS.
PACKAGE YEAH. AND FOR HERB
GREENING AND AT. A COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM. WE HAVE AND
THAT PROTECTING FISH AND WILD.
FROM CHANGING CONDITIONS
STREAMFLOW ENHANCEMENT- WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AND A PROGRAM TO
PROTECT WILDLIFE. FROM CLIMATE
IMPACTS SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF.
OF PROGRAMS ACROSS THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WILL DRIVE ON YOU
DON'T REDUCING THE IMPACTS OF
EXTREME HEAT AND PROTECTING- OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE FUTURE TO
BUILD RESILIENCE TO EXTREME HEAT
SO I JUST I WANTED TO SORT OF A
PROBLEM. NO I NAY AND- THAT'S I
MEAN THAT'S OBVIOUSLY WHAT THE
L. A. O. HAS BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION IS THERE A COHESIVE
STRATEGY FOR THIS THIRD PIECES
HERE PIECES HERE AND WE'VE- GOT
TO ADD ON THIS- I GOT A-
ESTABLISHED RECORDS OF EVERY
WILL FORGIVE ME. MISS ROY IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL AND TO FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING CORE.
LIKE HOUSEKI HERE. WHY CASKEY
HERE DOLLY. DALY ABSENT MCGUIRE
YOUR ACQUIRE. STERN YOUR SISTER
HAS A POINT. WE HAVE MEMBERS AND
ATTEND WEBER BEEN ESTABLISHED
VERY GOOD SENATE STERN YOU
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- FOR THE SAY THE OUTSET. I
APPRECIATE THE PINPOINTING OF
THIS. THIS ISSUE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE GOVERNOR
IN PARTICULAR I WANT EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE ON- CALLING OUT
EXTREME HEAT AS- WHAT IT IS
WHICH IS THE SILENT KILLER AND
THE LARGEST CLIMATE IMPACT IN
THE STATE THAT NO ONE'S REALLY
TALKING ABOUT- WE STILL. I THINK
ARE UNDERESTIMATING HOW MANY
PEOPLE DIE EVERY YEAR FROM
EXTREME HEAT INCIDENTS- ACTUALLY
IN THEIR HOMES BUT ALSO IN
STRESSES IT FROM THE WORKPLACE-
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S- THERE'S
A LACK OF COOLING AT NIGHT- HEAT
EXPOSURE. PRETERM BIRTHS THE
LIST GOES ON- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION-
HONING IN ON THIS CHALLENGE IN
TRYING TO PUT. A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE TOGETHER BUT I WANTED TO
BUILD ON- DEBBIE SECRETARY
HANSON'S- TO FLESHING OUT THERE
WHICH WHICH M. TO ME SORT OF
COULD ROUND OUT THE STRATEGY-
BECAUSE WHEN I READ THE
ANALYSIS. STATING THAT. THE
PACKAGE- DOES NOT HAVE A FUNDING
FOR- BUILDING LEVEL
INTERVENTIONS. SUCH AS
IMPROVEMENTS OF COOLING OR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY RETROFITS IN
PRIVATE RESIDENCES- THAT'S
CONCERNING- FOR WHAT I HEAR YOU
SAYING IS. IT'S NOT THAT IT'S
NOT IN THE PACKAGE IS JUST NOT
LISTED HERE IN THE CHART CAN WE
PLEASE TO HONE IN ON THAT
BECAUSE I NOTICED THAT FOR
INSTANCE THE ENERGY COMMISSION
IS NOT. AMONG THE CAVALCADE OF
AGENCIES INVOLVED HERE TODAY IN
THIS EXTREME HEAT STRATEGY AND
YET THEY'LL BE THE ONES- THEY
HAVE A SIX MILLION HEAT PUMP BY
TWENTY THIRTY GOAL N. ARE
HEADING UP THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION STRATEGY WHICH
HAS CRITICAL AREAS OF OVERLAP.
I'M I'D BE REMISS THAT WE WENT
AROUND AND INSTALLED A BUNCH OF
GAS BASED. I'M COOLING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE THEN HAD
TO. ABANDON THOSE STRANDED
ASSETS ONLY MAKE TRANSITIONS
AWAY FROM THE GAS SYSTEM SO CAN
EITHER DEPUTY SECRETARY YOU OR
SOMEONE ELSE WITHIN- WITHIN THIS
THIS FRAMEWORK MAYBE IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTOR KEY CAN YOU.
CAN YOU FLESH OUT THOSE PIECES
THAT AREN'T HERE THAT FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES- FIDELIO NOTED- DURING
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO RECOMMEND FOR
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WHO RELY ON
SAY PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND
WALKING IS TO GO MAKE A HOUR
LONG COMMUTE- WHEN THEY'RE
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND GOING
THROUGH- YOU KNOW THE EARLY
PHASES OF HEAT STROKE TO GO. TRY
TO FIND THEIR WAY TO A LOCAL
LIBRARY- THE BEST THING WE CAN
DO FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE SO
VULNERABLE IS KEEP THEM AT HOME
AND MAKE SURE THAT ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE IN RENTAL UNITS- THAT
THEIR LANDLORDS ARE ENSURING
THAT THEIR THEIR PLACES IS
SUFFICIENTLY COOL IN THAT. THOSE
BUILDINGS HAVE THE HEAT PUMP
CAPACITY TO KEEP THEM COOL- SO
CAN YOU CAN YOU ALSO JUST KIND
OF DIGGING ON THAT FOR A SECOND
EXPLAIN MAYBE WHY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS NOT INVOLVED WITH
THE EXTREME HEAT STRATEGY AND-
HOW SOME OF THESE OTHER
COMPONENTS YOU'D MENTION LIE
WITH. HOW YOU EXPECT THOSE TO
SOARED INTERFACE AT THE
RESIDENTIAL LEVEL. YES SO THIS
IS A NEW AND MARQUIS I WILL-
RESPOND HERE AND THEN I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY PARENTS THAT MY
CALLING A MOTHER HANSON TO WEIGH
IN AND ADD ADDITIONAL DETAIL- SO
YES WE AS WE WERE PULLING
TOGETHER BOTH THE EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN AND THEN. THIS IS A
PROPOSAL FOR THE SENATE SIDE.
REALLY WANTING TO TAKE. ALL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND
INTERDISCIPLINARY APPROACH
RECOGNIZING THAT EVERY SECTOR
AND ESPECIALLY EVERY STATE
AGENCY HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO
PLAY IN RESPONDING TO THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT ACROSS
ALL THE WORK THAT WE DO SO. NOT
JUST TO YOUR POINT SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THE ENERGY COMMISSION
THEY ABSOLUTELY WORK HE PARTNER
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE BOTH
THE EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN AS
WELL AS A PARTNER IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS AROUND. WHERE
THERE IS FUNDING NEED TO BE ABLE
TO DRIVE SOLUTIONS ON THE GROUND
SO ENERGY COMMISSION WHILE THEY
ARE NOT REFLECTED EXPLICITLY IN
THIS. EXTREME HEAT SATISFIED
FUNDING PROPOSAL THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS WHERE THEY
ABSOLUTELY ARE ENGAGED AND
INVOLVED IN SOLUTIONS AND I CAN
LET MY COLLEAGUE AMANDA HANSEN.
COVER ANY DETAILS THERE- WHAT
WHEN I'M DONE HERE BUT- TO YOUR
POINT THERE IS THAT YOU KNOW IN
THE- BUILDING THAT WAS AGREED TO
LAST YEAR AS PART OF THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION FOR EXTREME HEAT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION SET ASIDE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY. BUT
THE ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED WAS
AGREED TO AND PROGRAMS OUT FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
THE URBAN AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY
IN URBAN GREENING PROGRAM. A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE NEW
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE AND HE
PROGRAM AT OPR WHICH I SPOKE TO
A LITTLE BIT AND- EARLIER THERE
BUT REALLY LOOKING AT THAT
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HE PRODUCTION
ACTIVITIES PLANNING AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTATION ACTIONS
ON THE GROUND. THERE'S A.
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE FIRST USE
ABOUT THOSE I'M GOING AND JUST
FELL THAT RIGHT NOW- AND THEN
FIFTY MILLION THE LOWER. WHEN
IT'S A PRO AS WELL SO THAT FROM
THE- WILL DEPART SPECIFICALLY.
IN HALL. AND NEEDS COOLING
EFFICIENCY MANY THE THINGS
TALKED. SO IN ADDITION TO WHAT
WAS AGREED TO LAST YEAR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THIS IS
ALSO SUMMARIZED THE BEGINNING OF
THAT- BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION SET
ASIDE IN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
CONNECT THESE DOTS- THERE IS.
TEN MILLION FOUR- PROPOSED FOR
ON GOING TO ESTABLISH A
MONITORING PROGRAM TO TRACK
EMERGING INTENSIFIED CLIMATE
SENSITIVE HEALTH IMPACTS AND
DISEASES THROUGH THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROJECT IN YOUR
BUDGET. AND THEN THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
PROPOSED THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REALLY TO SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
PLANNING AND- FOR NATION ONLINE
GOOD ACTORS ON THE GROUND. AND
THEN THE LAST THING I'LL POINT
OUT TO IN THAT JANUARY BUDGET IS
THE SIX HUNDRED TWENTY TWO.
MILLION TO SUPPORT EQUITABLE
BUILDING DEEP HARPER STATEWIDE
LOW INCOME DIRECT INSTALLED
BUILDING RETROFIT PROGRAMS SO
YEAH ALL OF TAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN THIS B.
C. B. FOR THAT HE SET ASIDE BUT
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH THAT HE SAID
SCIENTISTS THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. LOOKING AT WHERE
FUNDING ONE TIME FUNDING WAS
NEEDED TO AUGMENT THE GAPS AND
WORK. IN OTHER PLACES. SHOULD
YEAH YES THANKS NOT JUST TO
BEFORE WE TURN TO THEM THERE
SECRETARY HANSON JUST JUST TO
HONE IN THEIR SO HUNDRED. FOR-RESULT CENTERS THE YOU MENTION
AS PART OF THE ADDITIONAL FOR
HUNDRED MILLION. THE THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO SORRY THAT'S IN A TO
THE SEVEN MILLION WE'RE AT HERE
TODAY SO A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION THEN FOR
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S JUST. THERE'S
ANOTHER. OKAY SO THERE'S- TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY IS NOT REALLY
THE NUMBER THE NUMBERS REALLY
TWO SEVENTY- JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF THIS AND THEN THAT
URBAN FORESTRY NUMBERS NOT
REALLY FIFTY MILLION IT'S REALLY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IF YOU ADD
ON THE ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
FROM THE- BUDGET PROPOSAL
EARLIER THIS YEAR. THE RIGHT WAY
TO THINK ABOUT THAT. NO BECAUSE
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THAT
WAS AGREED TO LAST YEAR IS. YOU
KNOW TARGETED TO A VERY BROAD
SET OF- AT ENTITIES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN UNDERSTOOD NOT HE
LOCUSTS THIS IS THE STATE
FOCUSED PIECE OF THE URBAN
FORESTRY STRATEGY IS THAT A FAIR
WAY TO PUT IT. ACTUALLY I WOULD
SAY THAT IT THEY THEY ARE OFTEN
VERY HE FOCUS IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT IT'S AN ELEMENT THAT'S
LOOKED AT WHAT'S REALLY
DIFFERENT ABOUT. THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE FIFTY MILLION IN THIS
THREE HUNDRED STATUS THAT. IS
THAT IT'S TARGETED PROTECTING
VERY VULNERABLE SCHOOL VERY CHIC
MARBLE SCHOOL UNDERSTOOD. YEAH
AND THEN AND THEN ON BUT ON THE
MA DESCRIBING ACCURATELY ON THE
RESILIENCE CENTER PIECE THROUGH
STC. IT'S IT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION PROPOSED IN THIS EXTREME
HEAT SET ASIDE BUT THEN THERE'S
AN ADDITIONAL. HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR THE SAME PROGRAM. THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY HE ORIENTED THAT
THAT SORT OF BROADER REACH YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
OTHER RESILIENCE ISSUES OUT
THERE BESIDES HE IS AT THE-
STATE FAIR WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
YEAH I WILL- GIVE AN INITIAL
RESPONSE AND THEN MY COLLEAGUES
FROM ST PETERSBURG CALIFORNIA
ATTENDEES DO BUT YES THE WAY YOU
CHARACTERIZE SKINNER THE HUNDRED
MILLION AGREED TO IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND THEN WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING FOR THE SENATE SIDE IS
AN- ADDITIONAL- FUNDING A
HUNDRED SEVENTY SO THE TOTAL YOU
REFERENCE TO TWO SEVENTY IS
CORRECT. THE FUNDING WOULD
ADDRESS ISSUES OF EXTREME HEAT
BUT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
RESILIENCE BENEFIT ACROSS
CLIMATE IMPACTS OTHER CLIMATE
IMPACTS AS WELL AND I CAN LET MY
COLLEAGUE PAUL BABBITT. BY A
SMALL DETAIL OR LAND AS. WELL NO
I THINK THAT PERFECTLY TURNED
YOU SENT JUST TO. THAT WE INTEND
TO BUILD. WHERE WAS SO AND- ARE
DESIGNED TO WITHSTAND EXTREME
HEAT AND SUPPORT COMMUNITIES IN
EXTREME HEAT AND OTHER CLIMATE
DISASTERS AND OTHER EMERGENCIES
SO THERE REALLY. COMPREHENSIVE
AND NOT SPECIFIC TO A SINGLE
FRAME ISSUE FOR BOTH THE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION AND
THE ADDITIONAL. INITIAL ONE
HUNDRED. CAN I HAVE MISS EHLERS
FROM ARE. THE L. A. O. COMMENT
ON THIS BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST IN YOUR COMPREHENSIVE.
EXTREME HEAT DID YOU CATCH THAT
THERE WAS WE HAD AGREED ON A
HUNDRED MILLION BUT THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION FOR TWO SEVENTY- BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF CENTER STERN I
DIDN'T GET IT AND SINCE WE'RE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE. HOW THE
REST OF THE SENATORS AND THE
LEGISLATORS WOULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING IN THIS AREA DID YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT. YEAH I MEAN YOU
CAN SEE- AND SORT OF THOSE
BULLETS WE GAVE YOU AS AS
OVERARCHING CONSIDERATIONS ONE
OF THEM IS THIS IS THIS IS NOT
IN ISOLATION YOU KNOW THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AND THEN WE ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THOSE PIECES- YOU KNOW FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA AND THAT SORT
OF THING. I THINK I THINK OUR
OVERARCHING POINT YOU IS REALLY
WHAT YOU ARE STARTING TO GET OUT
WHICH IS THINK ABOUT THIS
STRATEGICALLY AS A WHOLE WHAT
ARE YOUR PRIORITIES YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE KIND OF. YEAH I USUALLY
WE THINK THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT
IS ONE IMPORTANT ONE-
PARTICULARLY AS SENATOR STERN AT
NOTED GIVEN- THE VULNERABLE.
POPULATIONS WHO LIVE IN
RESIDENCES THAT ARE- ARE ARE
KIND MOST AT RISK FROM SOME OF
THESE CHALLENGES SO- I THINK
THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR
POINTS DO YOU IS THINK THINK
ABOUT THESE PIECES ALL TOGETHER
AND NOT NOT IN ISOLATION- BUT
THEN ACROSS ALL OF THEM. YOU
KNOW I THINK OUR GUIDANCE WOULD
BE WHAT ARE YOUR BIGGEST
PRIORITIES WHAT ARE THE
CATEGORIES OR AREAS THAT YOU
THINK. ARE MOST IMPORTANT ND I
THINK THEY ARE PART OF WHAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS HIGHLIGHTING AS
WE ARE STILL I THINK OF THE
STATE IN THE BEGINNING STAGES OF
DEVELOPING- A STRATEGIC PLANNING
GRAPPLING WITH THIS THIS CLIMATE
CHALLENGE THAT MINISTRATION IS
HAS ONLY VERY RECENTLY PUT FORTH
THAT THE EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN. YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
WORKING TOWARDS KIND OF WHAT OUR
GOALS WHAT ARE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES AND HOW DO WE BUILD
TOWARDS THOSE SO- DID DID THIS
IS A FOR THE FIRST THIS IS NOT
THE ONLY TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO BE AT DECIDING HOW
TO DEAL WITH THIS. BUT IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT BIG OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE SOME BIG PROGRESS GIVEN
THAT THE DOLLARS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST
CATEGORIES YOU WANT TO FOCUS AND
DOES THIS OVER ARCHING. PACKAGE
OF FUNDING NOT JUST. THIS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION BUT ALL THAT YOU
ARE TALKING A ABOUT. KIND A
BALLOT ALL OF THE PRIORITY IN
THE WAY YOU THINK YOU THINK ARE
MOST IMPORTANT. CENTER CERTAIN
THANK YOU. KNOW APPRECIATE THE-
CLARIFICATION THERE. I MEAN I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD WHAT I WOULD
ASK IS WE AS WE REFINE OUR GOALS
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION DIVING IN I DON'T
THINK WE CAN AFFORD TO WAIT TO.
FIGURE EVERY LAST DETAIL THAT I
THINK I THINK WEHAVE TO START
JUST LEARNING BY DOING AND I
THINK A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VERY WELL. TESTED AND
APPRECIATE THAT I GET THAT
THERE'S SOME NEWS NEW ELEMENTS
IN HERE AS WELL. FROM AN
OUTCOMES PERSPECTIVE THOUGH IN
TERMS OF THE METRICS THAT IS
DRIVING THE STRATEGY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION. WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE WHAT ARE THOSE SORT OF
WHAT IS THE CENTRAL METRIC FOR
DEFINING SUCCESS FOR THIS
EXTREME HEAT. STRATEGY WOULD YOU
SAY. BINANCE YOU WANT TO TAKE
THEM WITH YOU AND- YEAH I MEAN
I'M I'M JUST SAYING I'D MAYBE
EIGHT I CAN HELP. AT A POLICY
LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE IS IT HOW
MANY PEOPLE. WE'RE GOING TO BE
PROTECTING FROM EXTREME HEAT.
LIKE HOW HOW MANY HOW MANY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WILL BE
PROTECTED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL-
IS IT A SORT OF REGIONAL
COVERAGE ISSUE IS THAT. YOU KNOW
IT AND IT'S HONESTLY A PER. ACRE
PER MILE- YOU KNOW RATIO OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE I. MEAN
TO ME PEOPLE SHOULD ALWAYS DRIVE
IT AND SO. I BUT I DIDN'T I JUST
DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE THINK. THIS CURRENT
PROPOSAL INCLUDING ALL THE OTHER
ELEMENTS INCLUDING THE FIVE
HUNDRED ANDVERY IMPORTANTLY
NOTING THAT THE SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL
FOR EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PLUS THE
ADDITIONAL FIFTY. THERE'S A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BUILDING D.
CARD THAT WE EXPECT TO SEE IT GO
UP IN THIS IN THIS BUDGET- BUT-
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THIS STRATEGY.
HELPING. A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION I THINK. YEAH SOMETHING
THAT WE GRAPPLE WITH WHEN IT
COMES TO ADD QUANTIFYING THE
OUTCOMES OF CLIMATE RESILIENT
INVESTMENTS IS THAT IT'S VERY
DEPENDENT ON THE TYPE OF PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO THE
METRICS AND SORT OF GOT GOAL
POSTS ALONG THE WAY FOR THE
INVESTMENT IN THE EQUITABLE
BUILDING D. KERR- PROPOSAL IS
GOING TO THEY'RE NECESSARILY
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT FROM THE
METRICS. AND GUIDEPOSTS ALONG
THE WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO USE
TO MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
OUR- YOU KNOW WORKER PROTECTIONS
AND ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS AND SO
WHAT I THINK THE BIG PICTURE
MESSAGE TO YOU IT IS THAT AS WE
ROLL OUT EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS
THERE WILL BE TWO METRICS THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE MEASURING OUR
PROGRESS AGAINST. THAT DRIVE IN
PARTICULAR ON THAT THE
PRIORITIES FOR STATE ADAPTATION
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S SIX
PRIORITIES THAT WE'VE LAID OUT
BURKE AS NORTHSTAR'S WHEN WE'RE
INVESTING IN A CLIMATE RESILIENT
PROGRAM WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO
AND YOU KNOW THESE OUTCOMES ARE
YOU KNOW PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. YEAH MAKING
DECISIONS BASED ON BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE- AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE INCLUDED VERY SPECIFIC
SUCCESS METRICS IN BEING USED
DON'T DID TO MEASURE OUR
PROGRESS AGAINST THESE
PRIORITIES AND SO WHEN WE BUILD
OUT THE FINAL PACKAGE HERE WE'RE
GOING TO BE ENSURING THAT EACH
OF THE PROGRAMS BASED ON YOU
KNOW THEIR SPECIFIC- AREAS OF
FOCUS THE FACTOR THAT ARE
WORKING IN. THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DRIVING ON THOSE PRIORITIES AND
ARE GOING TO HAVE CLEAR METRICS
FOR SUCCESS IN YOU KNOW
PROTECTING PEOPLE BUILDING
COMMUNITY ANDECONOMIC.
SENATOR STERN IT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION TO HAVE
AT THE BEGINNING A IS WHAT WHAT
INFORMATION ARE WE LOOKING FOR
IF THESE ARE PILOT PROJECTS SOME
OF THEM AND WE'RE TRYING TO TEST
OUT AND SEE WHAT WORKS ARE WE
GONNA BE COLLECTING THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO COME BACK
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND DO THAT
SORT OF EVALUATION- SO AS MY
CALLING THIS ROW MENTION IN THIS
IN YOUR- AGENDA. THINKING ABOUT
IS THEIR DIGITAL RESEARCH AND IS
THERE SOME FUNDING THAT PERHAPS
SHOULD BE SET ASIDE FOR DOING SO
MUCH OF THAT WORK TO DO SOME OF
THAT RIGOROUS TESTING OF WHAT
DID WORK WHAT WHAT DO WE GET
FROM FROM THE FUNDING WHAT WERE
THE OUTCOMES- SO SOME OF IT
COULD JUST BE REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND PLAN INCLUDING THAT BUT BUT
YOU ALSO COULD THINK ABOUT ARE
THERE SPECIFIC RESEARCH
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE FUNDING
THAT NEEDS TO BE DEDICATED TO
DOING SOME OF THAT EVALUATION
SO. THAT AS AGAIN THIS PROBLEM
IS NOT GOING AWAY- WHEN WE'RE
REVISITING THIS IN A COUPLE OF
YEARS- AND THINKING ABOUT WHERE
TO MAKE INVESTMENTS DO WE KNOW
WHAT WHAT THAT KIND OF MOST COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACHES ARE. AND I
DON'T I WON'T BELIEVERS THE THIS
WILL BE JUST BE MY PHONE POINT-
DON'T WANTED THAT DON'T IMPLY AT
ALL- IN INTERESTING PUMPING THE
BRAKES IN FACT I'D RATHER
ACCELERATE THIS FURTHER I THINK
WE SHOULD BE DOING. MORE FOR
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS AND
HUBS- I THINK THAT WE CAN BUILD
ON AB EIGHT FORTY ONE AND IT'S
AN ACCELERATOR GREEN SCHOOLYARDS
AND SCHOOL RETROFITS PROGRAMS I
THINK THAT. THE WORK FORCE AND
ENFORCEMENT PIECE THE HEALTH
DATA SYSTEM ALL THESE ARE
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT. I'D I
THINK. EVEN THOUGH I RECOGNIZE
TO BE SECRETARY THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT TO SORT OF FIND
A SINGLE METRIC ACROSS THESE
SORT OF DIFFERENT CATEGORIES. IF
WE CAN IDENTIFY UP FRONT HOW
MANY PEOPLE EITHER THEIR
WORKPLACE OR THEIR HOME. ARE
VULNERABLE TO THIS PARTICULAR
CLIMATE IMPACT. AND HOW MANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE DO WE EXPECT THESE
INVESTMENTS TO MEET EITHER AT
THEIR WORKPLACE AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTER. AT THEIR HOME
WHEREVER THAT MAY BE. HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE AT RISK AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE DO WE EXPECT TO MITIGATE
THAT RISK FOR AND REALLY HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO HOW
WELL WE'RE DOING TOWARDS THAT I
THINK IT WILL GIVE. THE STATE.
PEOPLE TO STAY A LITTLE
SOMETHING MORE TANGIBLE TO WRAP
THEIR HEADS AROUND- IF THERE ARE
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS KNOW
THIS OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD
IT'S NOT IN THE BACKGROUND
REPORT BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CURRENTLY VULNERABLE TO EXTREME
HEAT IN CALIFORNIA HOW MANY TO
EXPECT TO BE IN THE FUTURE AND-
I MEAN THIS FOLKS TO EXPECT TO
HELP HERE SO. IF WE CAN GET THAT
RESOLVED TODAY OR GET SOME
INSIGHT I'M REALLY HOPING WE CAN
WORK ON THAT I'VE THROUGH
LEGISLATION. OR CERTAINLY
THROUGH YOUR YOUR ACTION PLAN
PERHAPS THE CODIFICATION THERE
UP SO. IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS I'D APPRECIATE IT BUT-
REALLY REALLY LOOK FOR DIGGING
IN HERE AND WORKING WITH YOU
GUYS THROUGH ALL THIS AND
ROLLING UP OUR SLEEVES BECAUSE-
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO. TO JUST
STUDY IN PUZZLE FOREVER HERE-
BUT YEAH ANY FINAL COMMENTS ARE
WELCOME. YEAH THIS IS NOON
TOMORROW JUST A QUICK- POINT TO
YOUR AND YOUR LAST POINT IN
TERMS OF. RESEARCH AND
UNDERSTANDING I WOULD JUST POINT
TO THE INVESTMENT THAT WAS MADE
YOUR LAST YEAR'S CLIMATE BUDGET
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENTS WHICH WERE AS YOU
KNOW SENATOR STERN CODIFYING.
UNDERSTANDABLE TWENTY AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW FROM- HE ARCED
PERSPECTIVE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
LOOKING AT THE- FIFTH PLANET
CHANGES THAT'S MEANT. AS ANOTHER
FEET AND HELP US ANSWER THESE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT YOU
RAISED TODAY SO. JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY AND FEED INTO THIS
CONVERSATION AS WE LOOK FORWARD. ONE FINAL. YOU'VE CAL FIVE TO
DO THE GROUP THE GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS. AND I WE UNDERSTAND
THAT URBAN FORESTRY COMES UNDER
CAL FIRE BUT WOULDN'T IT MAKE
MORE SENSE TO DEAL WITH THE
FIFTY EIGHT. A COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO ON ON THE
GREENING OF THEIR SCHOOL
PROPERTIES OR YOU KNOW I MEAN I
LIKE NATURE BASED WE'RE GOING TO
GET THERE MAYBE IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF BUILDING A PATIO COVER
IN SOME. AREA OF THE SCHOOL WHY
. HOW WITH THE SCHOOLS KNOW THE
GO TO CAL FIRE FOR THE
ASSISTANCE ON THIS GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS THE GREAT PART IS
THAT A NATURAL FIT THAT I'M
MISSING. YEAH WELL ACTUALLY I
THINK THE ANSWER IS A LITTLE BIT
YES- CALPERS BEEN DOING- SOME
OUTREACH TO SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- SO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEGUN ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH FOLKS- WITHIN
STATE AGENCIES IN EDUCATION- I
THINK THE BIGGER PICTURE
RESPONSE IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE. A
PLACE WHERE SCHOOLS THE FUNDING
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
INVESTING IS TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF SCHOOLS WHICH ARE
UNIQUE AND- I HAD SOMETHING THAT
WE THINK THAT. REQUIRED SOME
NUANCE AND SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO YOU KNOW THE GRANTS
THAT WE WOULD BE PROVIDING- I
THINK ALSO JUST WANT TO FLAG
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S- THERE'S
A- PARTICULAR INTEREST. IN THIS
PROGRAM TO BE FOCUSING ON
SCHOOLS THAT ARE AT THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO KEEP AND MANY OF
THOSE CALLS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE IN- YOU KNOW LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH. NOTHING
BUT ASPHALT AND- SO THERE'S A
REAL NEED FOR. THE WORK THAT CAL
FIRE IS EXTREMELY SKILLED IN
DOING WHICH IS REMOVING THAT
ASPHALT REPLACING IT WITH THREE
CANOPY BUT N ADDITION AND OTHER
SORT OF GREENING ELEMENTS. THAT
SUPPORT STUDENT LEARNING AND
HEALTH THAT COOL SCHOOLS AND CAN
REDUCE ENERGY COSTS. BUT ALSO
BECAUSE CAL FIRE HAS AN
INCREDIBLE GROUP OF TRAINED
PERFECT. URBAN FORESTERS THEY
ARE EQUIPPED TO SUPPORT THE AT.
MAINTENANCE MANAGERS IN SCHOOL
TO DO THE ONGOING MAINTENANCE
THAT IS GOING TO BE NECESSARY
FOR THOSE INVESTMENTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO I THINK HEALTHCARE
IS ACTUALLY A REALLY GREAT PLACE
TO START WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
PARTNERING VERY CLOSELY. WITH
OTHERS ACROSS OUR AGENCY I HAVE
DONE SOME COOL BRINGING PROJECTS
BEFORE THEY HAVE BEEN SOME SORT
OF. YOU KNOW ONE OFF HERE AND
THERE FIND FINAL POINT IS JUST
TO SAY WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH- DGS AND COLLEAGUES IN THE
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS- THE
DIVISION OF THE STATE ARCHITECT.
SO THAT THOSE COUNTY ENTITIES
THAT YOU MENTIONED WILL BE
ENGAGING WITH THEM AND ENSURING
THAT AS WE BUILD OUT THE
GUIDELINES AND IT YOU KNOW WORK
ON THE PROGRAM AND RAISE
AWARENESS OF THIS OF THIS
PROGRAM- THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE CHANNELS
AS WELL. I JUST I. WE'VE HAD
PROBLEMS GETTING ALL THE
CALGARY. APPROACH OF OUT ON FOR
PREVENT AND FIRE WILDFIRE- WOULD
CALIFORNIA BE BACK BEFORE US AND
THEY'VE TOLD US THAT THEIR-
WORKFORCES TIRED THAT THEY'RE
UNABLE TO DO THE- OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BECAUSE THEY'VE COULD
FIRE SEASONS BECOME A SEASON
LONG- SO. IT'S GREAT THAT THE
HAVE INDICATED TO YOU THAT THEY
WANT TO DO OUTREACH TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I'M JUST
SUGGESTING THAT THERE'S MANY A
TREE HAS BEEN PLANTED BUT IF THE
MAINTENANCE AND IT IT IT WILL BE
THOSE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
IN THE SCHOOL MAINTENANCE SITES
THAT WATER DAM. THAT MAINTAIN
THEM SO IT IS GREAT TO PLAN TO
SPEND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ON
PLANT TREES AND GET IT ALL BUT
I'M WORRIED ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
SEVEN YEARS DOWN THE LINE WHO'S
TAKING CARE OF THOSE. THERE'S
MANY A MANY A- REYES BED SCHOOL
GARDENING PROGRAM THAT HAS
NOBODY TENDING TO IT NOW BECAUSE
THERE THE TEACHER HAS LEFT AND
THERE'S NO PERSONALIDAD THAT IS
A SET UP ON THAT SO. THIS IS
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER
OPEN I. APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
COMMENTS I THINK THERE'S A-
HOPEFULLY. THEY'LL BE SOME
IMPROVEMENT HOPEFULLY FINANCE
THAT YOU SEE THE CHALLENGE WE
HAVE WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION CARVE OUT AN
ANTI ALL THE RIBBONS TOGETHER SO
THAT THE PUBLIC AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE NO WHAT ARE
EIGHT HOW ARE EIGHT HUNDRED IS
BEING. DEVELOPED AND IF THERE'S
CONSIDER IF THERE'S- OVERLAP AND
TELL US THAT THERE'S OVERLAP AND
THIS IS WHAT ALL THE ACTUAL
AMOUNT IS- BUT THIS IS. THE
FIRST CANDIDATE SO APPRECIATED
WE WILL. HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER OF
FOURTEEN WHICH IS OUR NEW ACER
NATURE BASED SOLUTION WE WELCOME
OF- DEPUTY SECRETARY HANSON
AGAIN WITH THEIR RESOURCE AGENCY
WE GET CAL FIRE WE HAVE THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD WE
HAVE THE CAL CONSERVATION CORPS
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION THE
DELTA CONSERVANCY THE TAHOE
CONSERVANCY AND THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAIN CONSERVANCY'S. CAL
RECYCLE FINANCE CDFA. GOODNESS
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA CONSERVANCY OF
LET'S GET STARTED. GO AHEAD
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS AMANDA HANSEN AND AGAIN
AND I SERVE AS THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE CHANGE AT
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY MY COLLEAGUE IS ALSO
GOING TO INTRODUCE HERSELF.
MORNING I'M JENNIFER NORRIS I AM
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
BIODIVERSITY AND HABITAT AT
THREE FOR THE AGENCY. I LEADER
THIRTY BY THIRTY EFFORT THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY. SO
WE JUST WANTED TO START BY
THINKING THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN ADVANCING A
RECORD SETTING CLIMATE BUDGET
LAST YEAR INCLUDING FOR CLIMATE
ACTION. IN THE SECTOR THAT WE
ARE DIVING INTO TODAY WHICH IS
THE NATURAL WORKING LAND SECTOR
MAKES UP APPROXIMATELY 90% OF
CALIFORNIA ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION ACRES. OF FARMS FORESTS
WETLANDS DESERT COMMUNITY GREEN
SPACES AND MARK. TREES PLANTS
GRASSES AND SOILS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN REMOVING AND
STORING CARBON FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND WHAT OUR
LANDSCAPES ARE HEALTHY THEY
PROVIDE A POWERFUL ST TO ABSORB
GREENHOUSE GASES AND THEY CAN
HELP US MOVE TOWARD OUR GOAL OF
CARBON NEUTRALITY. HEALTHY
PLANTS CAN ALSO PROTECT PEOPLE
AND NATURE FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BUILD OUR
RESILIENCE TO FUTURE CLIMATE
RISKS. VERY IMPORTANTLY THE
OPPOSITE IS ALSO TRUE. WHEN OUR
LANDS ARE UNHEALTHY THEY BECOME
ANOTHER SOURCE OF CARBON
POLLUTION RELEASING MORE
GREENHOUSE GASES THAN THE STORE.
AND UNDERMINING OUR EFFORTS TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY. IN
ADDITION UNHEALTHY LANDS
INCREASED CLIMATE RISKS TO
PEOPLE IN NATURE AND ARE MORE
VULNERABLE TO FUTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS. LAST MONTH WE
RELEASED THE FIRST EVER
STATEWIDE STRATEGY TO GUIDE AND
ACCELERATE CLIMATE ACTION ACROSS
OUR NATIONAL WORKING LANDS AND
IN ADDITION TO OUTLINING HOW
MANAGING. CAN SUPPORT OUR
CLIMATE GOALS THE STRATEGY ALSO
IDENTIFIES HOW THESE ACTIONS CAN
INCREASE EQUITY PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY EXPAND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S BIODIVERSITY. AT
THE SAME TIME WE RELEASED OUR
PATHWAYS TO THIRTY BY THIRTY
STRATEGY TO ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF
CONSERVING 30% OF OUR LANDS AND
COASTAL WATERS BY TWENTY THIRD.
THIRTY THIRTY IS PART OF AN
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT TO
PROTECT MAJOR AND CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTY BY THIRTY INITIATIVE WILL
CONSERVE OUR LANDS AND COASTAL
WATERS TO SAFEGUARD OUR UNIQUE
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. INCREASE
ACCESS TO NATURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND DELIVER CLIMATE
ACTION CAN BENEFIT. THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET COMMITTED ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS
FOR MULTI BENEFITS NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS INCLUDING A SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND SET ASIDE.
OVER TWO YEARS TO KICKSTART
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NATIONAL
WORKING LANDS CLIMATE SMART
STRATEGY AND PATHWAYS TO THIRTY
BY THIRTY WE RELEASED A
PROPOSED APPROACH FOR INVESTING
THESE FUNDS ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND. I BELIEVE IT'S LOCATED
ON PAGE TWENTY THREE OF THE
AGENDA HERE TODAY. THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION BUILD ON EXISTING
FUNDING TO ADDRESS CLIMATE AND
BIODIVERSITY CRISIS. IT
UNDERSCORES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ADVANCING EQUITY
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND IT
OFFERS THE OPPORTUNITY IT OFFERS
THE CHANCE TO REALLY ADVANCE
BOTH OF THE INITIATIVES. NEVER
WORKING MAN'S CRIMES ARE
STRATEGY AND THIRTY BY THIRTY
AND IT WAS DEVELOPED IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO FIVE KEY PRIORITIES
THAT EMERGED MORE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT THE FIRST WAS THE
STATE CAN REALLY SUPPORT
ACCELERATING IMPLEMENTATION OF
NATURE BASED SOLUTION. SO WE'RE
PROPOSING TO BUILD ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INVESTMENTS THREE THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
PROGRAMS THAT FUNDS STATEWIDE
NATURE BASED SOLUTION
IMPLEMENTATION. THE MAJORITY OF
THESE BONDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
TO PROGRAMS THAT YOU NO LONGER
HAVE FUNDING AVAILABLE OR VERY
LOW FUNDING FOR OUR NEW. THIS
AREA OF INTEREST THAT WE HEARD
FIRST STATE INVESTMENT IN ACTION
IS SUPPORTING REGIONAL ACTION.
SO WE'RE SO GRATEFUL TO WORK
ALONGSIDE SO MANY CLIMATE AND
CONSERVATION LEADERS. MANAGING
LANDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES FEDERAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
FARMERS AND RANCHERS LAND TRUST.
CONSERVATION CORES COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS THE
LIST GOES ON. AND ARE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS IN ACCELERATING NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THE THIRD AREA
OF FOCUS IS REALLY CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES OR CREATING
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG CLIMATE
LEADERS. ACROSS ALL REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WE HEARD AS WE
CONDUCT OUR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT WE
HEARD SIGNIFICAN ENTER INTEREST
IN DELIVERING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
CLIMATE AN OPPORTUNITY AGENDA.
YOU'RE EXPANDING OUR RESTORATION
ECONOMY JOBS IN MARKETS THAT
CONSTRUCT OPERATE MAINTAIN OR
OTHERWISE SUPPORT FEATURE BASED
SOLUTION. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONCEPT CORPS BLACK
OF LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. ARE
PROPOSING TO INVEST FIFTY TWO
MILLION FOR THE STATE COR TO
SUPPORT PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LOCAL
COURT IN NEW TRAVEL FOR. THE
FOURTH AREA FOCUS FOR OUR
PROPOSAL IS INCREASING OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES WERE
PROPOSING TO INVEST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
TRIBAL INITIATIVES THAT ADVANCE
SHARED CLIMATE AND BIODIVERSITY
GOALS THROUGH NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. THESE INCLUDE
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF TRADITIONAL
KNOWLEDGE CAPACITY BUILDING
TRIBAL NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
TRAVEL NATURE BASED CLIMATE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS. INCREASE
ACCESS INCOME MANAGEMENT OF
LANDS AND ANCESTRAL LAND RETURN
. THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE INFORMED
OR TRIBALLY LED AN INFORMED
PROCESS. WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH
BOTH PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT AND
GOVERNMENT A GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION WITH OVER SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBE
. AND THE FINAL. ELEMENT OF OUR
PACKAGE OUR PROPOSING TO INVEST
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO ADVANCE
SEVERAL NEAR TERM PRIORITIES
THAT REQUIRE PILOTING
CONSULTATION ANALYSIS OR
CONSULTING SERVICES. THE
MAJORITY OF THESE FUNDS WILL
SUPPORT LAUNCHING A PILOT
COMPOSTING PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
THESE FUNDS WILL SUPPORT THE A
NATURE WHICH IS A SUITE OF
INTERACTIVE MAPPING AND
VISUALIZATION TOOLS ADVANCED
THIRTY BY THIRTY. AND THESE
PLANS WILL ALSO BE USED TO
INFORM OUR APPROACH TO AREAS OF
NEAR TERM FOCUS FOR STATE ACTION
THAT REQUIRE CONSULTANTS
CERVANTES X. BURKE
RECOMMENDATIONS CONVENING.
ANALYSIS AND STAKEHOLDER
PARTNERSHIPS AND ENGAGEMENT. SO
I'LL JUST WRAP BY SAYING WE KNOW
THAT SUCCESS IN THIS SECTOR
REALLY REQUIRES OUR COLLECTIVE
ACTION AND WE APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP OF ALL THOSE I
MENTIONED AND THOSE THAT ARE ARE
ALSO CONTRIBUTING IN THE SPACE.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE TO-
NORTH DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING
SPECIFICALLY ON. BIODIVERSITY
THAT YOU WANT TO ADD TO THAT. NO
I'M ONLY THAT THESE INVESTMENTS-
WILL HELP US ACHIEVE THAT THE
THREE OBJECTIVES OF THIRTY BY
THIRTY YOU KNOW BIODIVERSITY
PROTECTION BEING PART OF THE
MAIN GOAL BUT ALSO INCREASING
OUR ACCESS NATURE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE SO WE CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT THIS
PACKAGE IS DESIGNED TO MEET ALL
OF THOSE NEEDS- COLLECTIVELY-
SECRETARY DEPUTY SECRETARY I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR. MY TWO
COLLEAGUES ARE ON THE DAIS HERE
BUT I KNOW THIS IS THE FIFTH
YEAR THAT THEY PUT MONEY INTO
WORKING LANDS AND NATURAL
SOLUTION SO WE'RE DELIGHTED THAT
THE REPORT THAT THE YOU CAME UP
WITH A YEAR THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
PLAN HAS BEEN DEVELOPED. WE ARE
HAVE A ALWAYS SEEN EYE TO EYE
WITH FINANCE WHO HAS TAKEN MONEY
OUT OF THE BUDGET IN PREVIOUSLY
YEARS SO WE'RE ALL GLAD THAT
WE'RE ONE BIG PARTY TOGETHER
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE. SO L. YOUR
COMMENTS ARE THIS. UP IT MORNING
SHERIN SENATORS TELLING CRISTINA
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE HAVE A FEW HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS ON THE PACKAGE AND
YOU'LL NOTICE SOME COMMON THEMES
BETWEEN OUR COMMENTS ON THIS
PACKAGE IN THE COMMENT THAT YOU
RECENTLY HEARD- ON THE EXTREME
TV PACKAGE AND SOME OF THAT
REALLY ROBUST CONVERSATION- ON
THAT PACKAGE I TRY TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS RELATIVELY SHORT I'M
THE FIRST THING I WANTED TO FLAG
IT'S REALLY THE PACKAGES FOCUSED
ON THE ADMINISTRATION GOALS. I'M
SO YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IT'S REALLY-
AIMED AT ACHIEVING THIRTY BY
THIRTY OR TRYING TO AT LEAST GET
US TOWARDS THIRTY BY THIRTY-
IT'S ALSO REALLY FOCUSED ON THE
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS I'M SMART
STRATEGIES- AND RECENT
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER SO
CERTAINLY- I THINK WE THINK THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
THAT WAS GOLDEN PRIORITIES ARE
WITH IT COOL THE PRIORITIES-
PLEASE AND THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES OF COURSE THAT
COULD- THAT COULD. THAT WOULD
BE- LOGICAL TO BE REFLECTED IN
AND WHATEVER THE FINAL PACKAGES
I WOULD ALSO NOTE ON THAT THAT
THAT MANY COMPONENTS OF THE
PACKAGE LACK MEASURABLE GOALS
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE THE NUMBER
OF ACRES UNITS GET COULD BE
THINGS LIKE NUMBER OF ACRES
TREATED- ARE CONCERNED AND THEN
HE SAID THOSE ARE AVAILABLE BUT
AND IN MANY CASES THEY ARE THERE
THEY AREN'T AND- YOU KNOW IN
SOME CASES THERE'S JUST LIKE
NUMBER GRANT THAT MIGHT BE
AWARDED- THAT'S USEFUL-
INFORMATION BUT REALLY WHAT WE
WHAT WE WANT TO PROBABLY. GET A
BETTER HANDLE ON IT ONE AT THE
END OF THIS RIGHT LIKE ARE WE
GET HOW MUCH CLOSER IF IT'S
GOING TO GET US TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY IF THAT IS THE GOAL OF
THE LEGISLATURE ONE- WHAT WHAT
SORT OF WAY AND WHAT REALLY WILL
BE CONSTRUED SO WE THINK IT
WOULD BE REALLY HAPPY REYES TO
HELP ALLEGE THE STAND WHAT TO
EXPECT THE FUNDING- WHETHER THIS
IS REALLY MOST COST EFFECTIVE
NEXT TO PROGRAMS TO KEEP THAT
YOU KNOW IF YOUR TO GET SET.
CONSERVING ACRES YOU KNOW WHICH
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE ARE BETTER AT
DOING THAT. AT HOW CLOSE IS.
THIRTY BY THIRTY EXAMPLE AND
THAT IS THE GOAL I AND THEN ALSO
YOU KNOW AFTER THE FACT WELL THE
NEED ACCOUNTABLE SO WE THINK ARE
REALLY IN. I LIKE WITH THE OTHER
P. WE KNOW THAT SOME OF THE-
SOME OF THE PRO THAT ARE IN
EFFECT ARE REALLY MORE
THEMSELVES ONE TIME FUNDING THAT
OTHERS SO WE JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS WHY- FORGET
SOMETHING LIKE ACQUISITION OF OR
EASEMENT THAT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
FOR OUT OF YOUR TO YOUR PACKAGE
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS LIKE CRAZY
FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S PROPOSED THE
FUNDING IS FUNDED AS PART OF.
THIS PACKAGE- THE THING IS IT'S
LIKE A AT. NIGHT LIKE TIFFANY.
BUT HE NOT A ONE AND DONE TYPE
OF THING AND THEN YOU TO DO-
YOUR- FAVORITE- FOR A LONG. TIME
FROM. IT'S KIND OF AN ONGOING
ACTIVITY SELF THINKING ABOUT.
THAT THAT MAKE THEM SENSE IN OF
AT TWO YEAR. AND WE WOULD ALSO-
THAT ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE
PACKAGE IS EQUITABLE FOR THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS AYE BUT
THERE'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IT IS INEXPLICABLE SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT LOGISTICS
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT-
ABSTRACTING ITS OVERALL BURKE
BUDGET AND CONSIDERING THE EVER.
OVERALL BUDGET ARCHITECTURE. I'M
ALSO JUST KNOW THAT SOME OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE FOR CERTAIN
COMPONENTS. IN PARTICULAR SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
FUNDED IN THE PAST. FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND-
AND CERTAINLY THAT THE FUNDING
SOURCE THAT COULD BE USED-
EITHER TO FIND SOME OF THESE-
AND POTENTIALLY REPLACE GENERAL
FUND OR OR AUGMENT- IF THERE
INCOMPLETE. IF YOU ARE LOOKING.
IN AND WE ALSO KNOW. THAT THERE
IS THE POTENTIAL OVERLAP IN
WHAT'S FUNDED IN THIS PACKAGE AS
WELL AS WHAT FIND IT ELSEWHERE
IN THE BUDGET I KNOW THIS IS A
BEEN. A YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I'M
WITH WITH A- BIG POINT. I'M IN
EXTREME HEAT CONVERSATION BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO VERY RELEVANT
HERE ON NATURE BASED RIGHT- A
LOT OF THE THINGS THEY DON'T
MISTER JEFF. THAT NEATLY IN ONE.
ONE AND YOU KNOW BUCKETS- SO FOR
EXAMPLE WELFARE. OF UT GRADING
OF FOR THE WEATHER PREVENTION.
PROGRAM THAT ALSO FUNDED IN THE-
WELFARE PACKAGE RIGHT THE ONE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
TRICKY I THINK FOR THE
LEGISLATURE GET. YOU KNOW
FOREVER TO GET OUR HEADS AROUND.
OKAY LOOK THINKING HOLISTICALLY
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THERE'S
SPENDING OTHER PACKAGES IN OTHER
PLACES. AS WELL. AND JUST ALSO
WANTED NOTE THAT A LACK OF HIM.
TO CHINA ON SOME OF THE PIECES
THIS PASS- ALSO HAD A COUPLE
EXAMPLE AND WE- ABOUT THAT.
MILLION FOR TRIED. AND ACTIVISTS
CERTAINLY SEEM REASON. TO AND-
SOME FUN. TO ADDRESS AND HOW IN
JUST. THAT HAVE BEEN HERE SICK-
I THINK ONE OF THE TWO. BILL
UNDERSTANDING EXACTLY HOW THOSE
FUNDS BE USED WE HAVE YOUR- THAT
IS- PROPOSED BE. RESPECTFOR TO
BE THIS TRAVEL I PROCESS- BUT
THE SIMPLE. SPECIFIC FOR HOW
THOSE FUNDS USED- YOU KNOW IT
COULD MEMORIALIZE THOSE- SO THAT
WOULD HELP. YOU KNOW HELP ENSURE
THAT WHATEVER BOTH LEGISLATURE
HAS. R. G. SIMILARLY FOR EXAMPLE
WITH A FIRE WILD. LIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD FINDING IT
COULD GO TO SUPPORT SIX
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. ON THE BOARD
WOULD BE IN CHARGE OF ALLOCATING
THOSE FUNDS LEGISLATURE COULD
JUST. THINK ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THE FROM
THE TRADE OFF. GIVE THEM MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT- THAT MAYBE
DOESN'T ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS QUITE AS MUCH CONTROL. AND
FINALLY WE NOTE THAT UNLIKE THE
OTHER PACKAGE THIS PACKAGE LIKE
THE COUNTY BILLION REPORTING
MEASURES. WE THINK THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW AFTER THE FACT. COMPARE
AND SAY YOU KNOW. THE WHAT IF
THAT'S GOT AS- AND YOU KNOW
REALLY WHAT WERE THAT WHAT WHAT
DID WE LEARN ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PILOT YOUR KEY PIECES THAT ARE
PILOT PROJECTS- SO THOSE ARE
SOME. REALLY PRETTY PROBABLY
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AREAS TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF REPORTING. BUT
JUST GENERALLY WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE ROBUST
REPORTING AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
GIVEN AT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT HEY- ARE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. NO I'M ON TOP OF THAT
THE- I UNDERSTAND MAYBE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HEARD THAT THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS IF ISSUED.
THEIR EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PROPOSAL SO WE GET TO
SORT THROUGH THAT WHAT WHAT THEY. HAVE ON. I GUESS LET ME JUMP
IN THE CUTS. CORPS WE TALKED WE
HAVE. TWO FOR. THE LOCAL TRY. A
NATURE SOLUTIONS- SO THERE'S
GONNA BE FOR TRIBAL CORPS WHAT.
WOULD THEY BE DEFERRED DOING
DIFFERENT THAN THE REGULAR COURT
IN THIS AREA OF NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS WHAT WOULD BE. THEN
THE FOURTEEN COURSE WE HAVE.
MISS THOMPSON. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- HELLO MY
NAME IS JIMMY THAT YOU B.
THOMPSON THIS IS SECRETARY FOR
TRIBAL AFFAIRS IN CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY-
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT USE FOR TRAVEL-
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND THIS IS
A NEW PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA-
CONSERVATION COARSENING AS
PROPOSING. AND THESE TRIBAL
CORES WILL WORK- DIRECTLY WITH
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES TO DEVELOP THESE
PROGRAMS. WE WOULD THIS WILL BE
A TRIBALLY LED PROCESS- BUT WILL
FOCUS IN ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OF FOR. SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD TRIBAL
YOUTH- THOSE INDIVIDUALS THOSE
USEFUL BEING IDENTIFIED BY
TRIBAL COUNCILS AND TRIBAL
LEADERS. AND THE WORK WILL- IT
WILL BE A MIXTURE OF PURSUING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. IN
TRAINING- WITH A FOCUS ON NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. AND SO THESE
CARS WILL WORK PRETTY SIMILARLY
TO CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
IS IN REGIONAL CORES- BUT WILL
BE VERY TIGHTLY LET AND FOCUSED
ON TRIBAL NATURE BASED SOLUTION
PRIORITIES. I AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH TRIBAL LEADERS- AND TRIBAL
COUNCILS IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THESE CARS. BUT IF A- THIS
THEY'RE DOING WHAT'S GOING TO
THE FORCED THEY'RE DOING FOR
THINNING. WHAT WE HAVE.
BIOLOGICAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE HISTORICAL DENSITY
SHOULD BE AND THEY'RE GOING TO
GO IN AND DO SOME CLEARING OF
UNDERBRUSH AND ALL THAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE- YOU CITY WILL BE LED BY.
TRIBAL PEOPLE. OR THEY WOULD. SO
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES WOULD BE- DEVELOPING
THESE CORES IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND SO THERE WOULD BE A
FOCUS ON TRIBAL NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PRIORITIES- THERE'D BE
A FOCUS ON TRADITIONAL
ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE- AND ALSO-
SUPPORTING THE STATEWIDE EFFORTS
IN THE NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS TO
YOU KNOW JUST OUT A BURSTING IN
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND SO YOU'LL
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR TRAVEL
USE. TO LEARN THE SKILLS THAT TO
HAVE THAT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT-
BUT ALSO LEARN FROM TRIBAL
LEADERS AND- CULTURAL
PRACTITIONERS AND- AND YOU GAIN
THOSE SKILLS AS WELL THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR NATIVE PEOPLE AND
NATIVE. COMMUNITIES OF OKAY I
GET I GET THAT THE TRIBAL BE
ENTERED THE END THE AND THAT
THAT PART OF IT I GOT IT I
DON'T. UNDERSTAND THE ACTUAL
WORK BEING DIFFERENT BUT- THAT'S
PROPOSAL- LET'S SEE MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS ON THE
NATURE BASED- OUR- PROPOSAL-
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- REPEAT A SIMILAR THEME TO
THE LAST TIME WHICH IS-
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION- PUTTING FORWARD
SOME. SOME PRACTICAL AND VERY
WELL GROUNDED SOLUTIONS AND
DIGGING IN DEEP ON OUR
BIODIVERSITY CRISIS ON OUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS- AND I
WOULD JUST ECHO AGAIN- I THINK
WE CAN GO EVEN BIGGER. AND
YOU'LL SEE THAT REFLECTED IN
WITH THE SENATE'S PROPOSED AND
I'M HOPING THAT WE- CONTINUE TO
BE AMBITIOUS ON THIS CRITICAL
PIECE OF OUR OF OUR CLIMATE
PACKAGE- I'M WONDERING IF TWO
QUESTIONS- HOW FOR TOWARDS OUR
GOAL- GOALS DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL GET US. AND WHAT WHAT ARE
THOSE THOSE GOALS AT THIS POINT. I'VE BEEN GOVERNOR AGAIN
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION YOU KNOW
THAT'S A REALLY HARD QUESTION TO
ANSWER WE'VE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE ANALYSIS
AND IT'S CHALLENGING AND I CAN
TELL YOU ONE OF THE REASONS AS
THIS- YOU KNOW. ACQUISITIONS AND
EASEMENTS IS ONE PIECE OF OUR
OVERALL STRATEGY TO ACHIEVE
THIRTY BY THIRTY- SO A LOT OF
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP US WITH
THAT THROUGH THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AS WELL AS
THROUGH CONSERVANCY- BUT AS YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW THE COST OF
ACQUISITION THEY'RE EVEN IF. A
HIGHLY VARIABLE ACROSS THE STATE
AND SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
HOW MANY ACRES PER DOLLAR YOU
CAN COUNT ON- AND AS YOU KNOW IN
FOR VERSUS- EVEN THOSE HAVE
WIDELY DIFFERENT COSTS SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO COME UP WITH THOSE
ACRES IN TERMS OF GETTING HOW
WILL GET US CLOSER TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY. I WILL ALSO POINT OUT
THAT WE EXPECT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO- CONTRIBUTE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF THIS RICH OUR GOAL I
DIDN'T AT. CURRENT TIME THERE'S
ABOUT A MILLION AND A HALF ACRES
BETTER IN FEDERAL PROCESS THAT
MAY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR OVERALL
GOAL. AGAIN THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PATHWAYS IN THIS IS JUST ONE-
BUT I THINK IT'LL MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNPAYMENT. AND IF
YOUR MOTHER WANTS TO ADD
SOMETHING. YES I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT. YOU KNOW WE KNOW. THAT
BASED ON THE MODELING THAT
CARBON IS DONE AND THEY'RE SORT
OF VERY FIRST INITIAL- ATTEMPT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SOURCES
AND THINGS OF OUR LANDS. WILL BE
IN THE FUTURE. AT THAT.
UNPRECEDENTED CLIMATE SMARTLY
AND MANAGEMENT IS NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO GET TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND YOUR LONG
TERM GLOBAL CLIMATE
STABILIZATION GOALS. SO AT WELL
I CAN'T NECESSARILY ANSWER THE
QUESTION. OF SORT OF
SPECIFICALLY HOW FAR WILL THIS
PACKAGE GET US. I CAN'T SAY THAT
IT IS CRITICAL TO BEGIN
INVESTING NOW AND TO CONTINUE
TO. MEASURE THE IMPACTS WHETHER
THOSE BE YOU KNOW THE KIND OF
RESULTS IMPACTS BUT IN
PARTICULAR. AT THE EMISSIONS AS
THE CLUSTERED OR AS- WE MOVED
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
REALLY ARE DRIVING CREDIBLE. AB
KIND OF BENEFITS. IT DID TO ME
WHAT IS CLEARLY A AT. AS HUGE OF
WORK AHEAD OF US IN THE SPACE.
M. I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
DIDN'T I MEAN I DIDN'T MEAN TO
IMPLY THAT. THAT ACREAGE OUGHT
TO BE THE SOLE METRIC OR OR THE
GOAL AND TO BE SECRETARY HANSEN
I MEAN YOU NOTED CARBON- I THINK
YOU KNOW BIODIVERSITY IS NOT
NECESSARILY ONLY DICTATED BY.
TOTAL NUMBER OF ACRES YOU COULD
CONSERVE. MILLIONS OF ACRES IN
THE WRONG AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
NO SENSITIVITIES AROUND YOU KNOW
SPECIES DECLINE AND YOU ACTUALLY
WOULDN'T IMPROVE YOUR
BIODIVERSITY RESILIENCE ANY
FURTHER SO. WHICH ACRES THEY ARE
MATTERS AND IN SOME WAYS SMALL
SMALL PROJECTS CAN YIELD HUGE
REWARDS LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE
BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY WHICH
IS TINY IN ITS FOOTPRINT. BUT
CAN HAVE MASSIVE EFFECTS.
IMPROVING THAT ESTUARY- FINDING
BIRD HABITAT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE METROPOLIS- AS WELL AS THE
SORT EQUITY GOALS THAT I THINK
SHOULD SHOULD BE DRIVING ALL OF
OUR WORK HERE- YOU KNOW. WE HAVE
UNDERLYING ACCESS GOALS- ACCESS
TO WILD OPEN SPACES ON THESE
THINGS MATTER TO I'M SIMPLY
SUGGESTING THAT WE START TO
ARTICULATE THOSE- IN THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY PROCESS AND I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE ALREADY PUT OUT YOUR-
INITIAL PLANNING DOCUMENT-
FOLLOWING UP AND- WE SUBMITTED
COMMENTS ON THAT. ON BEHALF THE
RESOURCE COMMITTEE OF A NUMBER
OF LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS- BUT ON
THIS THAT SORT OF ACREAGE POINT.
CONCEDING THAT IT OUGHT NOT
MAYBE BE OUR CENTRAL METRIC BUT
AT LEAST SOMETHING WE HAVE TO BE
TRACKING AND STUDYING AS WE GO
WAS THERE ANY- CONSIDERATION IN
TERMS OF TOTAL ACREAGE- UNDER
MANAGEMENT OR- THE SORT OF SCOPE
OF WHAT. EACH CONSERVANCY HAS ON
ITS PLATE- WHEN THE BREAK DOWN
OF THE REGIONAL THAT REGIONALLY
SUPPORTIVE ACTIONS WAS LAID OUT
I NOTICED THAT IT'S SORT OF.
EVEN ACROSS. A NUMBER OF
CONSERVANCIES AND I JUST WANTED
TO GET A SENSE OF. OF YOUR LOGIC
THERE I MEAN I JUST BY WAY OF
COMPARISON- YOU KNOW SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY SAN
GABRIEL LOWER L. A. RIVER AND
SAN DIEGO ALL HAVE THE SAME
PROPOSED. ALLOCATION WHICH IS
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS- PER YEAR OVER TWO YEARS
TO GET TO TWENTY TWO POINT TWO
AND THEN THAT ADDS UP- SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
I'M OVERSEAS ABOUT SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND ACRES IN THEIR THEIR
PLAN THAT THEY'VE TARGETED FOR
CONSERVATION. SAN GABRIEL HAS
BUT TWO THOUSAND SO ABOUT THIRTY
SIX TIMES LESS THAN THAT AND IN
SAN DIEGO HAS TWO HUNDRED TIMES
LESS THAN THAT WITH. JUST THREE
OR SEVENTY FIVE ACRES TARGETED
FOR. IN THEIR CONSERVATION
PLANNING SO- HOW DID THAT HOW
DID YOU SORT OF WAY THE SCOPE OF
WORK. THAT YOU'RE EXPECTING-
THESE OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO BE
DOING ON YOUR ON YOUR REGIONAL
ACTION PROPOSAL. I THINK THAT
QUESTION I WOULD SAY- YOU KNOW
FUNDAMENTALLY WE RECOGNIZE THAT
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO DO MORE AND THAT THERE'S PENT
UP. NEED AND LIST PROJECT SORT
OF THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS AND SO OUR INITIAL CUT
WAS TO RECOGNIZE THAT ALL OF OUR
CONCERNS YOU HAVE WORK TO DO AND
THAT WE SHOULD DISTRIBUTE FUNDS
ACROSS THOSE. BUT WE'RE OPEN. TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
FURTHER. READ IT APPRECIATE THAT
I'M I GUESS I WOULD I WOULD
JUST. I WOULD I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT AS WE CONTINUE LOOKING AT
THIS PROPOSAL AND YOU ALWAYS THE
SENATE PROPOSAL AND WE START TO
FLESH OUT THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
PLAN. WHICH WE'VE YET TO SORT OF
DIG INTO THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
RESOURCES COMMITTEES THINKING
ABOUT. DOING SOME- SOME
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THAT
WORD MISS NORRISYOU COULD MAYBE
COME IN AND YOU KNOW WE CAN
START TO- SHARE THE PLANNING%
MORE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
INSPIRING STUFF I THINK IT WILL.
GIVE A LOT OF COMMUNITIES MUCH
HOPE I WOULD JUST I WOULD SAY
THAT I'M- LOOKING TO WHAT THE-
THE CURRENT SORT OF SHOVEL READY
IF YOU WILL. ROGIC LIST LOOK
LIKE ACROSS THESE SORT OF
REGIONAL AGENCIES WOULD BE. MMHM
PERHAPS AN EFFECTIVE. TOOL I
KNOW THAT- IN OUR BACKYARD- IN
JUST THE EAST AREAS SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS AND RIM OF THE VALLEY
PLAN THAT- CONGRESSMAN CHIFFONS
CENTER PRETTY OF PROPOSED FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT-
THERE'S AT LEAST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN IMMEDIATE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS THAT WILL
OTHERWISE OF FALL PREY TO. TO
DEVELOPMENT- IN THE NEXT YEAR
TOO THAT'S A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ONE PORTION OF THAT
ENTIRE RIVER THE VALLEY AREA
ALONE AND THIS IS JUST ONE TENTH
OF THAT SO- LOOK FORTY DIGGING
IN DEEPER BUT I THINK. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. WHAT WE CAN DELIVER
ON QUICKLY KNOWING THAT
ACQUISITIONS ARE TOUGH. AND THAT
. PLACES MATTER AND THAT- YEAH
THAT THAT YOU KNOW WHAT'S AT THE%
HIGHEST RISK NOT JUST FOR
BIODIVERSITY- BUT ALSO FOR OVER
DEVELOPMENT AND FOR THOSE LANDS
BEING GONE FOREVER RIGHT THAT
COULD BE A USEFUL TOOL- BUT I
APPRECIATE THE WORK HERE AND-
AND ESPECIALLY THE THIS FOCUS
HAVE HUGE TRUST IN W. C. B. TO
GET THIS WORK DONE AND THEY'VE
DONE INCREDIBLE WORK OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. AND THEN
COMBINING THAT FINALLY BREAKING
THROUGH THE IMPASSE ON ON
REGIONAL ACTION I JUST WANT
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR YOU
ALL- YOU KNOW OPENING THAT.
OPENING THAT CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I WILL I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU THAT THROUGH OUR
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THEIR
REGIONAL GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THEY CAME FORWARD WITH
LISTS OF PROJECTS THERE ARE
PLACES ALL OVER THE STATE THAT-
PEOPLE ARE REALLY ECITED TO
PROTECT- AND WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE FUNDS SO. I TAKE YOUR POINT
. OBVIOUSLY THE- ELLIE- HAS
POINTED OUT TO US THIS CHALLENGE
OF QUALITY OVER QUANTITY. AND
IT'S THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC
PROPOSAL AUGMENTS THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US INTO
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN BY ONE.
BILLION DOLLARS ON BIODIVERSITY
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY TO
DO THIS WORK SO- SINCE WE HAVE
YOU IN FRONT OF US ALTHOUGH THIS
IS AN AUGMENTATION- AND IT'S
STILL SUBJECT TO NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
PARTICULARLY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY YOU
THERE'S GOODNESS IN THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE US. IS THIS THE
RIGHT BALANCE THE THIS IS THE
BALLOT IF WE COME IN WITH
ANOTHER BILLION DOLLARS WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE MONEY SHOULD
GO INTO THE THIRTY BY THIRTY. OF
THAT MONEY AT LEAST HALF OF IT.
EVERYWHERE BUT WE HAVE A BREAK
DOWN I'M NOT GONNA GO THROUGH IT
BUT BUT ARE WE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK WITH WITH GIVING MONEY TO
. PART OF NATURAL RESOURCES TO-
ACQUIRE EASEMENTS OR PROPERTY IN
ORDER TO MEET THESE ADMIRABLE
GOALS OF THIRTY BY THIRTY- AND I
ASK THAT QUESTION SOMEWHAT NOT
KNOWING WHAT THE QUALITY THE
QUANTITY RATIO IS GOING TO BE SO
IF YOU COULD JUST. I KNOW. WE'RE
HESITANT TO GIVE A FLAVOUR HERE
BECAUSE IT BUT I'M ASKING DIRECT
QUESTIONS SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WHEN ASKED A
DIRECT QUESTION THE MINISTERS
WILL RESPOND SO IS. IT THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION HOW WITH THAT
BEST BE SPENT IN THIS QUALITY
QUANTITY. RACIAL GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE MONEY IN THE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT ALREADY FORCING
YOU'VE ALLOCATED AS YOU SEEN FIT
. THANKS FOR THE QUESTION YOU
KNOW THE QUANTITY VERSUS QUALITY
QUESTION I THINK IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY WHY WE CREATED THIS.
AMONG THE REFERENCE THAT CA
NATURE WHICH IS OUR ONLINE
INTERACTIVE MAPPING AND
VISUALIZATION TOOLS THIS IS
ACTUALLY- INTERACTIVE MAP THAT
ANYBODY IN THE STATE CAN-
ACCESS. AND IT'S DESIGNED TO BE
USER FRIENDLY OR IF YOU'RE A
REALLY TECHNICALLY CAPABLE- THAT
PERSON TO USE OTHERS MULTIPLE
SORT OF. LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY BUT
ALLOWS YOU TO LOOK AND SEE WHERE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE CONJURATION
ALREADY THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
COMPARE THAT TO. BIODIVERSITY
HOT SPOTS PLACES WHERE YOU CAN-
ADD CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN
EXISTING PROTECTED AREAS LOOK AT
HOW THOSE PLACES WILL- BE
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
MOVING FORWARD SO- CHANGES IN
TEMPERATURE CHANGES IN
PRECIPITATION. THERE'S ANOTHER
YOU CAN USE A LAYER TO LOOK AT
WHERE WE HAVE A LITTLE ACCESS TO
NATURE. SO WHERE ARE OTHER
PLACES THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO NATURE SO YOU CAN USE
THAT TOOL. TO OUR SUITE OF TOOLS
REALLY TO IDENTIFY THE HIGHEST
QUALITY INVESTMENTS THAT WE CAN
MAKE. TO AND SO IT DIFFICULT
BENEFIT WIDE LEVEL BUT EACH SORT
REGION HAS THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THE MOST FOR THEIR BUCK HALF
I JUST NOTE THAT THE- THIS.
PROPOSAL HAS SIX HUNDRED AND-
MILLION DOLLARS DIRECTLY GOING
TO THE CONSERVANCY'S OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD SO WHAT WE SEE THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR. FOR
THEM THE ALL THESE THINGS WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT WE ANTICIPATE
HAVING A CONTINUE REPLACING
SHIPPED DIRECTLY WITH THE
CONSERVANCY'S FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY HAVE I KNOW THERE'S A
COUPLE OF BILLS TO EXPAND
BALDWIN PARKS IN SANTA MONICA.
SAID ON THE SAME THEME THAT YOU
GUYS ONE LAST QUESTION YOU'VE
GOT UNDER- YOU GOT TN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA THE
GRAZING- THE FUEL REDUCTION. MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS- YES GOES IN
REMOVES THE TOXIC MATERIALS
AFTER FIRE AND THEN CAL RECYCLE
COMES IN AND DOES THE- THE-
REMOVAL OF THE OTHER TIMBER-
DEBRIS- WOULDN'T IT MAKE SENSE
THAT THEY WOULD BE DOING. ONE OF
THOSE TWO AGENCIES WILL BE DOING
THE WORK. TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CAL FIRE WHO'S ON THE TO
HELP US IN THIS QUESTION.
BECAUSE IT'S ALSO COMMUNITIES SO
THAT WOULD BE. YEAH GET MORNING
CARE MEMBERS OF- THIS IS THE FOX
ASSISTANT- DIED DIRECTOR FOR CAL
FIRE IN ACTING POSITION- THIS IS
CENTERED AROUND THREE FIVE
MITIGATION FOR HAZARDOUS
REDUCTION I'M NOT FIRE. RECOVERY
THAT YOU'VE JUST TO GO WITH
CALLOW YES OUR EXPECT. OKAY
SENATE STURM THE LAST. HOPEFUL
THE SAID THE LAST WORD OF THE IS
THE BIG OF A AND CONVERSATION
AND APPRECIATE THE CHAIR SET A
BAR HI BECAUSE WE NEED TO GET
THEIR- JUST THE ONLY WAS ON.
HELLO THE FUNDING THAT THAT WERE
TALKING ABOUT- FOR- FOR TOMORROW
FISH AND WILDLIFE ON A NATURAL
COMMITTEE CONSERVATION PLAN TO
ENHANCE NCC. IN THE HABITAT CON
. PLAN EFFORTS. I'M I'M I'M
REACTING TO SOME THAT. THE MISS
NOTED. THE PLAN F. THAT TO
PRISSY AND SORT OF UP HI QUALITY
THAT ALSO HIT SAY SOME QUAN
GOALS. MIKE MY CONCERN RIGHT NOW
IS THAT A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVEN'T DONE THAT
WORK OR SAY THE CONSERVANCY'S
HAVE THAT CONSERVE PLANNING IS
THERE A IS THERE AN EFFORT UNDER
WAY- TO AYE DRINKER. OR REQUIRE-
EITHER LOCAL GUY OR AGENCIES- TO
SAY PUT A CONSERVATION UP THEIR
CON PLAY UPDATE THEIR OPEN SPACE
PLAN I KNOW IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE I THINK THE
CITY IS NOT UPDATED ITS OPEN
SPACE PLAN SINCE NINE SEVENTY
THREE. WE DONE OUR HOUSING L.
BUT- AND THAT'S IN YOU KNOW
PENDING WITH HCD BY. HOW IS
THERE A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE OR
REAL JURISDICTION THAT ARE SORT
OF. THEY'VE GOT THOSE THOSE
ADOPTED PLANS IN PLACE IF YOU
WILL AND MAYBE DFW IS NOT.
EXACTLY THE PLACE TO BE DOING
THAT I KNOW I YOU KNOW- AND
BIASED HERE I'VE GOT LEGISLATION
PENDING AS WELL THAT THEY WOULD
REQUIRE AS MUCH- BUT AT THAT
WOULD YOU KNOW MANDATE THAT THAT
OCCURS BUT THERE AY BE A
CARROT. CARROT APPROACH HERE TO
ADD THOUGHTS ON THAT. YES THANK
YOU WE YOU KNOW WE'RE DEFINITELY
IDENTIFIED THAT AS AN IMPORTANT-
TASK IN OUR IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY ONE OF THE PATHWAYS AS
PART OF REGIONAL- STRATEGIC
CONSERVATION. YES THERE ARE YOU
KNOW ANTICIPATED EIGHT CPUS THAT
ARE DONE THAT WE CAN INVEST IN
AND SOME OF THE FUNDING WOULD GO
TO THAT. SOME OF IT ALSO WOULD
BE TO HELP- OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVEN'T YET STARTED- IF THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN THAT THERE'S ALSO
MONEY I'LL POINT OUT FOR THE
REGIONAL CONSERVATION INVESTMENT
STRATEGY- PROGRAM- WHICH IS
ANOTHER. A DIFFERENT VERSION OF
THE SAME. WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE-
REGIONAL CONSERVATION PLANNING
STRATEGIC PLANNING BUT THAT CAN
HAPPEN TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AVENUES THE ONES WE'VE
IDENTIFIED HERE ARE. TRIED AND
TRUE BUT THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER
LOCAL EFFORTS WERE FOLKS COME
TOGETHER AND- AND DO THAT WORK
SO IT'S PART OF WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARD I KNOW
DSW'S IDENTIFIED SOME PLACES-
ACROSS THE STATE WHERE THERE IS
NEED AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
TO. INCENTIVIZE THEM BUT IT BUT
A WILLINGNESS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO- TO SORT OF
RIORITIZE AREAS WITH. PLANS
THAT HAVE BEEN ADOPTED WITH WITH
CONSUMMATE. YES HI. I THINK WE
WANT TO DEFINITELY RELY ON THAT
STRATEGIC THINKING RIGHT BECAUSE
THAT IS THAT IDENTIFIES PLACES
BUT- THE COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED
YOU KNOW WHERE THEY WANT TO SEE
DEVELOPMENT AND WHERE THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING COMPENSATION
THEY- USUALLY DONE THE VERY HARD
WORK OF. IDENTIFYING THE KEY
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION AREAS
THAT THEY NEED TO YOU KNOW FOCUS
ON. SO YES THOSE KINDS OF
STRATEGIC PLANS WILL HELP US
MAKE SURE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS. ARE WIDE THANKS. MISS
CHRISTIAN WHO ANYTHING THEY- NO
YOU I'M HAPPY THINK ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BUT NOTHING ELSE ADDED
WELL I AM I LOOK FORWARD TO
READING READING THE MAY REVISE
IN THIS. PROJECT HERE AT HOPE
EACH OF YOU GET A COPY OF- THE
SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL ON
CLIMATE ADAPTATION LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD
IN A COOPERATIVE AND- IN LIKE
MANNER- OF WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION DISCUSSION
WILL MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN. PESTICIDE
USE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM YEAR'S
BUDGET- BILL LANGUAGE AND SOME
BCPS. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS JULIE
HENDERSON I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. AND I LIKE TO JUST
START WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT OUR MISSION IS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT BY REGULATING
PESTICIDES SALES AND USE AND BY
FOSTERING REDUCE RISK PEST
MANAGEMENT. WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE STATE'S PESTICIDE
REGULATORY PROGRAM EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE STATE'S
PESTICIDE USE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS IS ESSENTIAL TO
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. ENFORCEMENT IS A
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
DPR THE STATE LEVEL AND COUNTY
AYE COMMISSIONERS AYE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. RIGHT OVERSIGHT OF
LOCAL. ENFORCEMENT IF COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AND
THEIR STUFF. OUR VISION IS TO
ACCELERATE THE SYSTEM MY
TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT.
STEWARDING OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT FUTURE FOOD
PRODUCTION AND SUPPORTING
EFFECTIVE URBAN PEST MANAGEMENT
. WE'RE ENGAGING AND
COLLABORATING WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO SUPPORT THIS
TRANSITION TO BETTER PROTECT
HUMAN HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT
PARTICULARLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IF YOU ARE HIS
PROPOSED THREE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AND TODAY I'M
PRESENTING IT OUR PROPOSAL TO
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. THE PROPOSAL WILL
ENSURE THAT THE STATE HAS
MULTIPLE TOOLS TO ENFORCE
STATEWIDE COMPLIANCE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE REQUEST IS FOR EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND FROM THE
DVR FUND FOR THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO INVESTIGATE AND
DEVELOP PESTICIDE RESIDUE AND
USE ENFORCEMENT CASES. AND FOR
FUNDS TO HIRE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO REPRESENT
DPR IN CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
PESTICIDE USE OF FORCE IN
ACTIONS. WELL THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PESTICIDE USE IN CALIFORNIA
COMPLIES WITH STATE LAW AND
REGULATION STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS WILL BETTER
DETERMINE ACTORS AND IN DOING SO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
THOSE WHO USE PESTICIDES
RESPONSIBLY. THE PROPOSAL ALIGNS
WITH OUR GOAL TO EXCEL. THE
TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT MY
STRENGTHENING ENFORCEMENT TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE. AS WELL
AS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO BETTER
ENSURE PESTICIDE USE THE SAFE
AND RESPONSIBLE. THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WOULD REINSTATE
DVRS ADMINISTRATIVE PESTICIDE
USE ENFORCEMENT AND PENALTY
AUTHORITY AS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL
AT THE STATE LEVEL. IT WOULD
ALSO INCREASE STATUTORY
ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL PENALTY CAPS THAT HAVE
REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR DECADES.
AND BETTER ALIGN WITH USEPA
PENALTY LEVELS AND OTHER COUNTY
PA TTL LEVELS. IT WOULD ALSO
STRENGTHENED APPEARS PESTICIDE
RESIDUE ADMINISTRATIVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. AND I
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE WORKED
. WITH END REALLY APPRECIATED.
THAT WORK WITH THE COUNTY AYE
COMMISSIONERS ON CHANGES
REGARDING ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
ADMINISTRATOR OR SPENT AND
PENALTY AUTHORITY- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HAVING ME TODAY AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
IMPRESSIONS YEAH THAT WAS THE
QUESTION IS. ARE WE STEPPING ON
ANY COUNTY COMMISSIONERS TOES
HERE I MEAN THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR
HOME OKAY. I THOUGHT FIFTY EIGHT
IS FIFTY. NINE FIFTY SIX OTHER.
OPENINGS. YES VERY GOOD QUESTION
- WE ARE NOT STEP ON A FOR. THIS
WHERE LEAVE PLACE THE CURRENT.
WHAT THIS- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WOULD ADD IS I'M OUR ABILITY IN
THE CASE OF. MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL VIOLATIONS TO BE
ABLE TO FROM A STATE OVERSIGHT
LEVEL I'M TAKING FORCING ACTIONS
AND THE SOUTH- ADMINISTRATIVE.
PENALTIES IN THOSE CASES ANY
OTHER INSTANCE WOULD BE IF THERE
IS A COMMISSION ARE- THAT DOES
NOT CARRY OUT HIS OR HER DUTIES
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
BACKSTOP IN THAT CASE. MYSTERY
MENACE WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS IT SEEMS
LIKE A REASONABLE PROPOSAL TO
YOU. YEAH GOOD MORNING MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FRANK
MENACE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES THE PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT OF PESTICIDE
PENALTIES. SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO PESTICIDE USE RESIDUE- AND
SALES THAT LICENSING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL EXPANDS
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY FOR DPR IN
TWO MAJOR WAYS. FIRST THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE PPR WITH THE AUTHORITY
TO LEVY MINISTRY TO PENALTIES
FOR PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS I'M
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT HAVE THAT AUTHORITY. I
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY BEING REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL COURSE MCCARTY WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO SERVICE THE
BACKSTOPS. TO LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
WHEN MERITED SUCH IS- SERIOUS
SMALL JURISDICTIONAL VIOLATIONS
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING- COUNTY
ACT. COMMISSIONER AS THE PRIMARY
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. BUT
ALSO REESTABLISH THE MERITORIOUS
DEPARTMENT- PREVIOUSLY HELD-
SECOND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE DPR WITH-
ADDITIONAL RESIDUE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY- THIS IS- AREAS SUCH
AS ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT TO
LEVY ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
I'M TWENTY DAYS THAT DISTRIBUTE
OR MOVE PRODUCE I'M TO HAVE BEEN
QUARANTINED IT OF POTENTIAL
ISSUES WITH PESTICIDE RESIDUE. I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE ADDITIONAL FORTY
BEING REQUESTED WE FIND THAT
THESE CHANGES COULD BETTER
ENABLE THE STATE TO PREVENT
CONTAMINATED PRODUCE FROM
REACHING CONSUMERS- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
INCREASE IN ESTABLISH NEW
PENALTIES ACROSS VARIOUS TYPES
OF PESTICIDE VIOLATIONS. I'M
THESE CHANGES CAN BE FOUND- IN A
TABLE IN YOUR AGENDA- THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE
DIRECTOR TO ADJUST CERTAIN
PENALTIES FOR INFLATION IN
FUTURE YEARS. OVERALL WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE-INCREASED PESTICIDE RELATED
PENALTIES AND ALLOW FOR
INFLATION ADJUSTMENTS IN FUTURE
YEARS IN MANY CASES- COUNTY
LEVELS HAVE NOT BEEN INCREASE IN
SEVERAL DECADES HAVE. LOSS
THERE- RELATIVE ABILITY TO DETER
VIOLATIONS OVER TIME. HOWEVER
INCREASES COULD INCLUDE
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PENALTY LEVELS WHILE
MUCH APPEAR REASONABLE OR
SETTING PENALTY LEVEL SOMEWHAT
HIGHER LOWER BASED ON WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DEEMS APPROPRIATE TO
ACHIEVE ITS GOAL AND DETERRING
VIOLATIONS. I'M FINALLY THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING
TO SUPPORT DPR PESTICIDE USE AND
RESIDUE ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE FUNDING OF BEING
WORK- DO THIS BY WITH ANY THE
PART TO CONDUCT THE LOTUS. WITH
THE PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT OF PENALTY ADORE
ADORE DAVE AND ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO. REFER BY. TO THE
ATTORNEY OFFICE- HAPPY TO A
QUESTIONS YEAH ON POINT IF THE
STAFF OF INDICATES THAT IT'S
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR AND IT WE'RE GONNA GET
ONE OF THESE CASES EVERY TWO
YEARS SO IT'S BASICALLY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A CASE.
TWENTY TO YOU CAN JUST GO OUT TO
THE- TO. THE ZILLIONS OF
ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
THEM DO THIS ENFORCEMENT. ACTION
BECAUSE THAT THEY BE ENFORCING
THE LAW WARD OR WHO'S GOOD WHO
DOES THE ENFORCEMENT NOW
INTERNALLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
WHEN THEY HAVE A CASE. MINISTER
COST SAVINGS HERE BY USING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- YES ENTER IT I
BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDING THAT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WOULD BE LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR THREE YEARS
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT- D.
HISTORICALLY THE PR HASN'T HAD
MANY REFERRALS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THIS WOULD
BE. A RELATIVELY NEW ACTIVITY
AND WOOD ALL ATTEMPTS TO BE SEEN
AS A PILOT AT THE END OF THE
THREE YEARS WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
SEE- THERE ARE FILES THAT-
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
REFER TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND- THE SUCCESS OF- THIS
FUNDING AND- WHAT HAS BEEN- WHAT
ARE THE OUTCOMES OF IT- BUT- I
WOULD PREFER TO THE PART AND-
THEY HAVE BEEN RIGHT. ADD ON TO
THAT I MEAN IS IT A IS IT A
RETAINER THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BOXES COULD BE ON THAT IT'S
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THREE
YEARS OF COVERAGE. AND THIS IS
JULIE I'M HAPPY TO JUMP IN HERE-
NO THIS WOULD NOT BE A ROUTINE
OF THIS WOULD BE FOR ACTUAL
FEES- AT. THAT ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND- JUST TO- PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT WE WORK REGULARLY. WITH
THEM ON ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
MATTERS RELATED TO THE APARTMENT
AND THEY HAVE. A LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE RELATED TO OUR WORK
AND SO- THIS WOULD BE- IN CASES
WHERE. IT'S THIS IS WHERE IT
WOULD BE BUT- TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE
ARE MULTI JURISDICTIONAL CASES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT- FROM HAVING
ATTORNEY GENERAL REPRESENT US IN
MORE SERIOUS CASES- BUT- REGULAR
CASES THAT WE WOULD NORMALLY
HANDLE WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
HANDLE AT THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL.
AND NOW IF YOU DID HAVE A
SERIOUS CASE. CURRENTLY YOU HAVE
TO INTERNALLY USE MONEY THAT YOU
HAVE AND REALLOCATE OTHER BOB
BOB. POTS OF MONEY TO COVER THE
ATTORNEY FEES TO PURSUE THIS-
BAD ACTOR. EXACTLY RIGHT SO THIS
WITH THIS HELLO. IF I'M OUT
THERE IN THE WORLD OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES- THAT I WOULD SAY IF
I WAS GOING TO IT NOT IF I WAS
GOOD OVER SPRAY OR NOT CLEAN
THE- RESIDUE FROM MY- FRUITS
BEFORE A PRODUCT TO MARKET AND
CREATED HAZARDOUS SITUATION AT
LEAST FOR THREE YEARS THERE'S
NINE HUNDRED. MIL NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF ATTORNEY
FEES TO COME AFTER ME SO YOU
IT'S SORT OF WOULD SERVE OR
<c.magenta>IGHT JUST STRETCHING THIS AS A</c>
POLICING ACTION FOR ANYBODY
WHO'S OUT THERE THAT WOULD THINK
THAT THEY THEY THEY CAN GET AWAY
WITH IT BECAUSE NOBODY'S GONNA
BE WATCHING THAT THE EXTRA STAFF
AND THE FACT THAT THE HIRED GUN.
AT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
IS READY TO PURSUE YOU MAYBE.
MAYBE NOT I DON'T KNOW. IT'S A
VERY GOOD QUESTION I THINK WE'VE. AS BEING A KEY EFFECTIVE
DETERRENCE I'M IN IN THINKING
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO REFER CASES TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ON THOSE CASES
THAT. REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE MORE
CHALLENGING FOR US TO HANDLE AT.
THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL. OKAY VERY
GOOD STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HOLD OPEN ANYTHING ELSE FINANCE
. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
TO ADD TO A DOCTOR ANDERSON BUT
IT WELL THANK. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR HENDERSON THANK YOU-
ALLEY- LET'S MOVED HER LAST ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN WHICH WAS
REMOVED. LAST WEEK BREAKING NEWS
. DIRECTOR WILLIAMS GOOD TO SEE
YOU. GOOD MORNING I GUESS I'LL
START OFF THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN WITH THE PARTNER TAXES
SUBSTANCE CONTROLS WITH THE
SANTA SUSANA FIELD LAB CLEAN UP
TEAM AND I WILL START OFF WITH
THE CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND ALL THE PARTIES
FOR THE AGREEMENT WITH THE
BOEING- AIRCRAFT AND THE OTHER
PARTIES OF INTEREST FOR THE- M.
O. U. AFTER FIFTEEN LONG MONTHS
OF NEGOTIATING AND- HERE'S OF
RED- CONTAMINATION SO.
CONGRATULATIONS BUT VIEW YOU
STILL HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
FOURTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS SO
TELL US ABOUT IT. WHAT WE DO WE
DO INDEED AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR NEGRI WILL TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH- I'M FRANCESCA NAZARIAN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL AND WE'RE
GONNA HERE TO- TALK PRESENT YOU
TODAY ON OUR PROPOSAL FOR- CLEAN
UP ACTIVITIES ACTIVITIES THE
SENTENCES THAN A FIELD
LABORATORY OR F. AS A FELON
VENTURA COUNTY. SO AS YOU
INDICATED YOU HEARD THE
ANNOUNCEMENT EARLIER THIS WEEK
REGARDING AN AGREEMENT THAT D.
T. S. C. M. BOEING REACHED-
RELATED TO CLEAN UP OF THE SITE-
WE REACHED A COMPREHENSIVE
SETTLEMENT FRAMEWORK WITH HE%
BOEING COMPANY RELATED TO CLEAN
UP OF THEIR AREA. AT SFL. D.
ASIAN AGREEMENT FINALLY RESOLVE
DISPUTES OVER BOEING'S
OBLIGATIONS TO SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP. DEVELOPS A
PROCESS FOR- ACHIEVING A
COMPREHENSIVE CLEAN UP AND LIMB
LET LIMITS DELAYS FROM FURTHER
LITIGATION. AND WILL RESPOND TO
SOME QUESTIONS LATER ON IN DR
WILLIAMS HAS SOME COMMENTS
RELATED TO- THAT MEDIATION.
HOWEVER THE BUDGET REQUEST IN
FRONT OF YOU IS BROADER AND
INVOLVES DTS HE'S OVERSIGHT OF
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES AT THE
ENTIRE SITE BY MULTIPLE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES INCLUDING
NASA AND THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY ALONG WITH BOEING.
SPECIFICALLY THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING A TOTAL OF THREE POINT
ONE MILLION AND FOURTEEN
POSITIONS ON GOING FOR THESE
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES THIS
INCLUDES TWO POINT ONE MILLION
FROM THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT AND ONE MILLION FROM THE
FEDERAL TRUST FUND. THE
POSITIONS REQUESTED INCLUDE
EIGHT POSITIONS THAT ARE SITE
MITIGATION AND RESTORATION
PROGRAM AND SIX POSITIONS IN OUR
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL. YES IS
THE BELL SITE JUST FOR SOME
BACKGROUND AND CONTEXT THAT FUND
TWENTY NINE HUNDRED ACRES IN THE
HILLS OF VENTURA COUNTY AND WAS
IN USE IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AS A ROCKET
ENGINE TESTING. AND NUCLEAR
POWER RESEARCH FACILITY OPERATED
BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
NASA AND BOEING. SITE CLEANUP
ACTIVITIES OVERSEEN BY DGSE HAVE
BEEN ONGOING SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE AND INCLUDE REMOVAL
AND DISPOSAL OF OVER FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND CUBIC YARDS OF
CONTAMINATED SOIL AND OTHER
MATERIALS. AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTATION OF A GROUND WATER
EXTRACTION AND TREATMENT SYSTEM
. WHILE THESE CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES HAVE ADDRESSED-
SIGNIFICANT CONTAMINATION AT
SOME EARLY CLEAN UP AREAS A
COMPREHENSIVE SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP APPROACH ON
THE ENTIRE AS ISABEL FIGHT IS
STILL NEED IT. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT THIS
CLEANUP WHICH WILL BEGIN
FOLLOWING CERTIFICATION OF THE
PROGRAM ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT FOR P. E. I. R. WHICH IS
NEAR COMPLETION. THE THREE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY NASA AND
BOEING ARE NOW UNDER BINDING
AGREEMENTS THAT COMPEL A SCIENCE
BASED STRINGENT CLEANUP OF THE
CONTAMINATED SOIL AND WATER AT.
THEN AND WILL REIMBURSE THE
DEPARTMENT FOR ALL THESE COSTS
AS WELL AS FUND THE CLEANUP
ACTIVITIES. THESE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES HAVE BEEN REIMBURSED TO
THE APARTMENT- THE DEPARTMENT
COUGH FOR YEARS AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH THIS
HISTORICAL PRACTICE. AND THE
DEAL WE ANNOUNCED THE FUNDING
HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL
APPROPRIATIONS. ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS SPECIFIC TO THE P. C.
P. BUT FIRST DR MEREDITH
WILLIAMS DGSE DIRECTOR WOULD
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
REGARDING THIS THE ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT YOUR FRIENDS THIS WEEK. DR
WILLIAM. THANK YOU FOR JESSICA
AND GOOD MORNING CHERYL CASKEY
AND MEMBERS. AS YOU WELL KNOW
MONDAY WE ANNOUNCED AN AGREEMENT
WITH BOEING THAT HOLDS AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO TIMELINES
PROCESSES AND STANDARDS FOR A
STRICT CLEANUP AT THE SITE. I'M
HERE TO PROVIDE CLARIFICATION
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
THAT ANNOUNCEMENTS. ON THE ELBOW
THIS HEARING AND CLEARLY IS NOT
A TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
YOU HEAR YOUR ANY FAX DIRECTLY
FOR ME- FIRST I HAVE TO
REITERATE THE OVERVIEW THAT-
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR NEGRI
PROVIDED. AFTER YEARS OF
LITIGATION AND INACTION THIS
AGREEMENT ALLOWS FOR CLEAN UP TO
A HIGHLY PROTECTED AND NEARLY
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL. I A
RESIDENT IT FOR A RESIDENT WITH
GARDEN CLEANUP STANDARDS. WHICH
WOULD ENSURE THAT IT WOULD BE
SAFE FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE ON THAT
LAND. AND CONSUME PRODUCE GROWN
IN THEIR BACKYARD GARDENS. THIS
IS A STANDARD THAT'S LONG BEEN
ADVOCATED FOR BY MEMBERS OF THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. IT RELIES
ON AND WILL BE GUIDED BY THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE BAD
SCIENCE IS DIRECTLY IN LINE WITH
USEPA GOT. HONEST INTERFERENCE
TO THE SCIENCE REQUIRES THAT WE
FOLLOW IT EVEN WHEN ELEMENTS OF
THE STANDARDS CHANGE. ANY
ASSERTION THE DDS DGSE HAS
WATERED DOWN THE CLEAN UP
STANDARDS IS FALSE. THE
AGREEMENT SUPPORTS A CLEAN UP
THAT IS BOTH SCIENTIFICALLY
RIGOROUS AND PROTECTIVE OF HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME THIS
MORNING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
NEBRIINAE BOMBS BEFORE TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. SO HOW ARE YOU. THIS
IS OF HISTORICAL M. O. U. HIGH
STANDARDS- STRICT SCHEDULE
SCRIPT DISTRICT TIMELINE.
SHOULDN'T WE BE SHOULDN'T THEY
BE ASKING FOR TEMPORARY
POSITIONS RATHER THAN PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO DO THIS WORK OF TO
WORK COULD BE DONE. WHAT IS YOUR
TAKE ON IT- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN OF BREAKING MINUTES
AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S BEING FUNDED ON A
REIMBURSEMENT BASIS SO IT
WOULDN'T BE FUNDED FROM ANY OF.
THE FEES AND TAXES THAT SUPPORTS
DTS USE NORMAL ACTIVITIES SO
FUNDING WOULD COME DIRECTLY FROM
I'M RESPONSIBLE PARTIES- I
GUESS. THE FUNDING IS LIMITED
TERM IN NATURE BUT- ONCE CLEAN
UP IS COMPLETED REIMBURSEMENTS
ARE ARE. FULLY REALIZED I THINK
THAT'S ONE FUNDING WOULD WOULD-
TRIGGER OFF- BUT I WOULD FOR
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR. THE
SPECIFICS ON THAT WILL
PRESUMABLY WE CHANGED THE FEES
THAT WERE PROTECTED IT R. HI-
COLLECTED LAST YEAR SO THERE'D
BE. I DON'T THINK CALIFORNIA
LACKS A NUMBER OF TOXIC SITES
THAT NEED TO BE CLEANED UP AT
THE END TO DO IT I GUESS THAT'S
MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS. THE
MIX BETWEEN THE LAWYERS AND THE-
CLEAN UP PEOPLE I DON'T I'M
ENGINEERS I GUESS- ARE YOU
SATISFIED WITH THAT. I THINK
IT'S SIX LEGAL POSITIONS OF THE
FOURTEEN IS THAT RIGHT A DEPUTY
NAY GRIEF. YES BUT ANOTHER THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE US AND ELLOS
FINE WITH THAT. YEAH WHEN IT
COMES TO THE NATURE OF THE B. C.
B. OUR OFFICE HAS NO CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL. OKAY- FINANCE
SOMETHING ELSE I SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
GIVEN THIS HISTORIC NATURE IS TO
APPROVE AS REQUESTED. YEAH
CHRISTIAN BUDGET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FURTHER
AT NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AND-
IF THE COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS HAPPY ADDRESS THAT'S-
JUST CONGRATULATIONS ALL AROUND
WE HAVE- THIS IS MY TWELFTH YEAR
IN THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTOR
WILLIAMS WE HAVE HAD PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS AND I HAVE- SET AS
A CHAIR OF THE POLICY COMMITTEE
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND IT NEARLY
A DAY THAT WE HAVE A TRIUMPHANT-
ATMOS REALLY WE HAVE TODAY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF- TOXIC
SUBSTANCE SO CONGRATULATIONS. TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF COULD WORK
ALL AROUND ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUESTION BY CENTER STERN. OKAY.-THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AS
SOMEBODY REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THEM.
THE EX TOXIC WASTE SITE I'M
GOING TO WITHHOLD ANY
CONGRATULATIONS AT THIS POINT- I
HOPE YOU APPRECIATE MY
SKEPTICISM. GIVEN THE TREMENDOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS THAT WE'VE
p. AND THEN ALSO FORGIVE MY
SKEPTICISM ON ANYTHING THAT-
THAT THE BOEING COMPANY IS
WILLING TO AGREE TO GIVEN THEIR
HISTORIC INTRANSIGENCE ON. ON
CLEANING UP WHAT HEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IS IN PUTTING
THEIR DOLLARS ON THE LINE SO I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I KNOW
WILL BE GETTING DEEPER INTO THIS
AT THE COMMUNITY FORUM ON JUNE
SECOND- BUT THE FACT THAT-
WHATEVER NEGOTIATION LED UP TO
THIS AGREEMENT- WAS NOT DONE IN
PUBLIC REQUIRES THE UTMOST
SCRUTINY AT THIS POINT SO I'M
NOT INTO. NOT PREPARED TO.
TISSUE CONGRADULATIONS OR EVEN
ANY- YEAH ANY ANY SORT OF TACIT
ENDORSEMENT OF THIS AGREEMENT
TELL WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE DRILL
DOWN ON SOME OF THESE KEY
QUESTIONS SO LET ME LET ME JUST.
GOIN ORDER HERE MAYBE DOCTOR
WILLIAMS- OR- FOR THE DEPUTY
WANTS TO TAKE A SHOT AT IT BUT-
WHAT WHAT STANDARD IS D. T. S.
C. IN THE EPA USING TO CLAIM.
THAT THIS IS THE- STRICTEST
POSSIBLE CLEANUP STANDARD. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR DIGGING IN IT IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT.
EVERYBODY HAVE FAITH IN YOU IN
THIS AGREEMENT AND THEN WHAT WE
WERE GOING TO REQUIRE BOWING TO
DO WE- THE PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE SIDE AND LIVE IN
THE SHADOW OF IT DESERVE NOTHING
LESS SO. YOU ASK ABOUT THE
CLEANUP STANDARDS AND I DO NEED
TO BE CLEAR THAT WE HAVE NOT.
ESTABLISHED A CLEANUP STANDARD
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT DONE WE'LL
SEE FOR SO WE ANTICIPATE
APPLYING THE MOST RIGOROUS
STANDARD POSSIBLE THE SITE. BUT
THAT CLEANUP STANDARD WON'T BE
FINAL UNTIL WE CERTIFY THE
PROGRAM VARMINT IMPACT REPORT
LATER THIS YEAR. BUT IT IS OUR
GOAL TO REQUIRE BOWING TO CLEAN
UP TO WHAT WE CALL A RESIDENT
BEFORE YOU KNOW. AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT AS THE STRICTEST.
WE'RE REFERENCING THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CENTRAL. AND
ALTHOUGH THAT WATER DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY. DIDN'T SPECIFY A
STANDARD OUTLINED A RANGE OF
POSSIBLE EXPOSURES. A RECREATION
OR STAND A RESIDENTIAL STAND- A
RESIDENTIAL SCENARIO- A
RESIDENTS TO DIFFERENT
RESIDENTIAL SCENARIOS WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE GARDENS IN
THEIR BACKYARDS AND ALL OF THOSE
SCENARIOS A RESIDENT WITH A 100%
GARDEN SCENARIO DOES PRODUCE THE
MOST STRINGENT CLEAN UP AND
THAT'S WHAT THE AGREEMENT CALLS
FOR. NORMALLY WE SET OUR RISK
BASED STANDARDS BASED ON LAND
USE AND WE WOULD TYPICALLY APPLY
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP STANDARD TO
THE SITE BUT OF COURSE WE WANT
TO ENSURE EVEN MORE PROTECTIONS
IN ANTICIPATION. OF POTENTIAL
FUTURE LAND USE AND IN LIGHT OF
THE EXTENSIVE CONTAMINATION AT
THE SITE SO. I JUST FIVE POINT
OF REFERENCE A RESIDENT WITH
GARDEN CLEANUP STANDARD HAS ONLY
BEEN USED IN JUST A HANDFUL OF
SITES AROUND THE STATE. AND I
WAS VERY HEARTENED TO SEE THAT
STANDARD AND THAT'S WHAT WE IN
THE COMMUNITY BEEN ASKING FOR A
VERY LONG TIME JUST WHAT THE
METHODOLOGY IS TO ARRIVE AT THAT
RESIDENTIAL GARDEN STANDARD I
THINK IS EVERYTHING THE DEVILS
IN THOSE DETAILS- CAN YOU
COMMENT ON. THE CONCERN AROUND-
THIS STANDARDIZED RISK
ASSESSMENT METHODOLOGY- A YOU
YOU BRIEFLY MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS BUT HAS THE HAS
THAT- THE ACRONYM IS THE
CERAMBYCIDAE SERAM BEEN. ALTERED
TO FIT. THEM THIS THIS CLEAN UP
AGREEMENT. SO AS YOU WILL HOLD
THE IT IS A COMPLEX CLEAN AND SO
THE SCHRAM WILL STANDARDIZE RISK
ASSESSMENT METHODOLOGY WAS
DEVELOPED TO PROVIDE VERY
SPECIFIC DETAILS OF BOEING ABOUT
HOW TO PERFORM. AND APPLY A RISK
BASED CLEAN UP AT SFO. AND SO WE
NEEDED TO DOCUMENT THIS
METHODOLOGY BECAUSE AS I
HIGHLIGHTED A RESIDENT WITH
GARDENS STANDARD IS NOT NOT
WIDELY USED. SO THE METHODS
OUTLINED IN THE SCHRAM HAVE
REMAINED THE SAME. WHAT DGSE
ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
USING AUTHORITATIVE VALUES AND
GUIDE. AND IN THIS CASE WE ARE
USING VLUES IN GUIDANCE THAT IS
CURATED AND UPDATED ON A REGULAR
BASIS. SO THE SCHRAMM WHO NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED TO REFLECT THOSE
CHANGES. SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS YOU YOU DID NOT UPDATE THIS
RAM TO ACCOMMODATE- AND THEN GO
OVER THE AGREEMENT BUT THAT.
IT'S OUT OF ITS IT DOESN'T IT'S
NOT CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT EPA
GUIDANCE IS THAT THAT. NOT QUITE
THE OPPOSITE OKAY WE DIDN'T WE
DIDN'T- NO MODIFY THE SCHRAMM TO
REFLECT TO TRY TO GET TO AN
ANSWER WE DIDN'T PREDETERMINE
AND ANSWER THEM BACK INTO IT BUT
NOT BY ANY MEANS- BUT YES THIS
IS FULLY CONSISTENT WITH U. S.
EPA GUIDE AND I IN FACT THEY USE
A VERY SIMILAR PROCESS WHEN THEY
USE THEIR RECENT RESEARCH-
CALCULATORS. IN THAT THE BIG
POINTS AS TO AFFORD HATED
DATABASES AND DATA SOURCES AND
USE WHATEVER DATA ARE PUBLISHED
IN THOSE DATABASES AND DATA
SOURCES AT A GIVEN TIME AND SO
THAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE REFLECTING THE
UPDATES TO BOOK AND GUIDANCE AND
ANY SOURCE DATA TO GO INTO THE
TRAP. AND I AM CALCULATIONS VERY
CALM AND I HAVE TO JUST SAY YOU
KNOW I'M A PHD PHYSICIST I DON'T
USE MY SCIENTIFIC CHOPS EVERY
DAY IN MY WORK BUT THIS IS AN
EXCEPTION IN THIS CASE I DID
VERY DEEP INTO THE INTO THE
CALCULATIONS UNTIL I WAS
CONFIDENT THAT THE WORK WHICH
THEN THE WORK OF OUR
TOXICOLOGISTS AND I WAS
CONFIDENT IN THE METHODS AND WE
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WALK
YOU THROUGH THE CALCULATIONS AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY
AND WE WANT EVERYONE TRAXXAS
CLEAN UP TO BE CONFIDENT THAT
WE'RE INSURING A HIGHLY
PRODUCTIVE ENOUGH SO. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE BEST
SUPPORTING INFORMATION THAT
LEADS TO THAT SO THAT WAS- ABOUT
THE SCHRAM AVAILABLE CAN I JUST
SO JUST. TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
THE- THIS TO JUST TO MAKE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS VERY COMPLEX AS
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE FOR MYSELF
AND FOR ALL THE CONSTITUENTS
LISTENING- I UNDERSTAND THIS
GETS DOWN TO HOW MUCH TOXICITY.
CAN BE UP TAKE IN SAY. A TOMATO
PLANT OR WHATEVER YOU MAY BE
GROWING IN THAT GARDEN SUCH THAT
IF YOU CONSUME THAT FOOD THAT
FRUIT WHATEVER IT WAS THAT YOU
WOULD. AT THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF YOUR LIFE I THINK THAT YOU
HAVE NO- FORESEEABLE RISK OF-
CARCINOGENIC EFFECTS SO. THE IS
THE DISAGREEMENT OR THE
SKEPTICISM- FROM COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES ABOUT. HOW MUCH THAT
PLANTS WILL UPTAKE- THAT THAT
SORT OF TOXIC MATERIAL ON SITE
HOW MUCH WOULD ACTUALLY END UP
IN WHATEVER THAT TOMATO IS THAT
PIECE OF FRUIT. YEAH SO. YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT THERE- SO
THE COMBINATION OF THE AMOUNT OF
CONTAMINATION THAT THAT IT WOULD
TAKE UP AS WELL AS THE AMOUNT OF
CONTAMINATION THAT'S LEFT ON THE
PLATE SIMPLY BY. YOU KNOW HAVING
SOIL EVEN EVEN IF YOU WASH YOUR
PRODUCE YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO REALLY REALLY SPEND ENSURE OR
VEGETABLES THAT STILL HAVE SOME
RESIDUAL SOIL SO THOSE ARE THE
TWO THINGS THAT ARE TO GO INTO-
THE CALCULATION THAT'S- TWO OF
THE THINGS THAT GO INTO THE
CALCULATION SO YES. WHEN WE GO
AND WE LOOK AT THE GOVERNING
DOCUMENTS THAT SAY THIS IS HOW
MUCH LETTUCE AND WE TALK ABOUT
LETTERS BECAUSE LETTERS DOES
TEND TO TAKE UP MORE SOIL. FIRST
OF ALL TAKE UP MORE
CONTAMINATION AND- JUST SERVICE
AREA WIDE PICK OF- OBSERVE. A
LOT OF SOIL MIGHT ADHERE TO IT
SO IT'S A VERY CONSERVATIVE WAY
WAY. TO DO TH CALCULATIONS SO
WE BASE EVERYTHING ON LETTUCE
AND IN THE CASE OF LETTUCE- ONE
OF THE VARIABLES ONE OF THE DATA
SOURCES DID CHANGE ON. OVER THE
YEARS AND SO WE'RE PASSAGE.
PRECISELY WHERE THE CONCERN IS.
I APPRECIATE THAT M. LISTEN WHAT
WILL HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE OFFER
OF A OF A BRIEFING TO DIG DEEPER
I WOULD SAY. JUST FOR TO BUILD
THE MOST PUBLIC TRUST POSSIBLE.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE WHATEVER THOSE
BRIEFINGS ARE DONE IN A IN A
PUBLIC FORMAT- BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY HAS MANY QUESTIONS SO-
I WILL I WILL DEFER THAT TO THE
TO THE JUNE SECOND EVENT AND
TAKE- WHATEVER- BACK UP
TECHNICAL INFORMATION YOU ALL
HAVE IN THIS OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
PAGE AGREEMENT- THAT WILL BE.
REVIEWING WITH OUR TEAM IN GREAT
DETAIL I DID WANT TO NOTE
HOWEVER FOR THE PURPOSES THE
ITEM TODAY MAYBE THE CHAIR
COULD. COULD CLARIFY WELL I'M
WITHHOLDING. MY JUDGMENT ABOUT
THIS AGREEMENT AND AGAIN
HEARTENED ABOUT RESIDENTIAL
GARDEN BUT WE WANT THAT TO BE
REAL AND DEPENDABLE AND THAT LD
US TO BE. SAFE IF IT TRULY IS
GROWN THERE- THAT- THAT WHAT
WERE THE BUDGET ITEM TODAY IS
NOT ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW YOU THE
M. O. U. ITSELF FOR ANY TACIT
APPROVAL OF THIS AGREEMENT. BUT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT- ENFORCEMENT-
A HAVING ENOUGH STAFF O LOOK
AFTER THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ISSUES. AND THAT- THE
COST THE POSITIONS AS I SEE
HERE- WILL BE FUNDED. THROUGH
COST RECOVERY FROM THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES SO GET CAN
YOU OR OR MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT.
JUST COMMENT ON ON THAT JUST TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT. THAT THESE
POSITIONS WERE FUNDING TODAY ARE
SORT OF NO REGRETS ENFORCEMENT
POSITIONS. THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY A TACIT APPROVAL OR
SOME- ENDORSEMENT THE AGREEMENT
BUT INSTEAD- ARE POSITIONS THAT
WE BE FUNDING UP FRONT AND THEN
WOULD BE IN THE COST WOULD BE
THEN RECOVERED FROM DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY NASA AS WELL AS BOEING
SO I HAVE THAT RIGHT. LUCKILY I
CENTER STERN WE HAVE BRIAN-
BROWN WHO IS THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CAN YOU CONFIRM
THAT ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN
PROPOSAL BEFORE US IS SIMPLY FOR
THE FOURTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO THE TUNE OF. OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
AND IN A MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL TRUST ACCOUNT OF
FOR- PERNAH POSITIONS WHICH WILL
BE REIMBURSED BY THE- AT THIS IN
THIS CASE THE- THREE PARTIES
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN SANTA
SUSANNA. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR STERN- THAT IS
CORRECT THE FUNDING THAT IS
BEING REQUESTED IS TO SUPPORT-
THE CLEANUP OF THE ENTIRE THANK
TO OVERSEE THE WORK THAT THE
THREE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. WILL
ENGAGE IN TO CLEAN UP THE-
DECLINE OF THE SITE NESB FUNNY
NEVER REQUESTING FOR THE
POSITIONS. WILL BE RUEFULLY
REIMBURSED BY THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY THROUGH CONTRACTOR FEDERAL
FUNDING. SO UP FRONT FUNDING.
FOR FOR CLEAN UP OVERSIGHT THAT
THAT THEN WON'T BE AT TAXPAYER
EXPENSE- BASED ON THE
REIMBURSEMENT- FROM THE RESPONSE
PARTIES. THAT'S RIGHT WE ISSUE
INVOICES- OR THOSE CONTRACT THAT
WE DO WE DO TECHNICALLY GET PAID
ARREARS BUT IT IS FULLY
REIMBURSED AND WILL NOT AFFECT
THE- THE FEES FOR EXAMPLE THE
FEES THAT WERE INCREASED WHO ARE
OF THE REFORM LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR OKAY UNDERSTOOD. ALL RIGHT
I I'M I'M COMFORTABLE AT THIS
POINT WITH WITH THE ISSUE THAT
THE ITEM BEFORE US MISTER CHAIR
BUT- APPRECIATE IT YEAH DR
WILLIAMSON AND THE REST OF THE
TEAM. YOUR OPENNESS TO DIGGING
IN DEEPER HERE AND- LOOK FORWARD
TO. TO KICKING THE TIRES ON WHAT
WHAT HAS BEEN AN ONGOING- AN
ONGOING MORAL THAT THAT WE STILL
HAVE NOT. FULLY REPAID TO THIS
COMMUNITY SO- IN ORDER GETTING
THAT DONE I'LL BE SPORTING HERE
TODAY. I APPRECIATE THE-
EVERYONE ELSE I KNOW THIS WAS IN
THE SPECIFICS OF THE AGENDA ITEM
BUT I THOUGHT GIVEN THE-
PROXIMITY TO THE- THE HEARING
AND THE CONTINUATION FROM LAST
WEEK THAT IT WAS WELL WORTH IT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC- HEARING PROCESS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANYBODY
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA- AS REMINDERS TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO DO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE. INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS- ON TESTIMONY- I'M
ASKING MEMBERS OF PUBLIC PP
BRIEF LET'S START WITH THE
WITNESSES IN OUR ROOM. TWELVE
HUNDRED HERE AT THE- STREET
BUILDING PLEASE COMPORT. THAT
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND STAFF RECALL MUSTARD AND
AUTO WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND. A FIRST I WANNA. COMMENT
ON TWO OF THE ITEMS NUMBER
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN BUT I WANT
TO START BY THANKING SENATOR
STERN FOR YOUR COMMENTS. ON
EXTREME HEAT- I. HAVE BEEN
LOBBYING SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
RESTORE FUNDING TO THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND HAD IMMERSED MYSELF IN
IT WHAT I CAN LEARN ABOUT
EXTREME HEAT MOSTLY FROM THE
LUSKIN. SCHOOL AT UCLA. AND YOU
HAVE TO START. WHERE PEOPLE LIVE
FIRST SO THAT HE PUNKEDBY THE
IS GOOD PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
LEAVE THEIR HOUSES TO GO TO THE
COOLING CENTERS ARE RESILIENT
CENTERS WHEN THEY HAVE
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
AND OTHER FRAILTIES THAT MAKE
THEM VULNERABLE TO EXTREME HEAT
IT'S THE SAME UNDERLYING
POPULATION IT WAS WELL
OVERLOOKED COVE IT. SO I WOULD
SUGGEST TREE CANOPY AND GREENING
AROUND HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
BEFORE WE- BUILD BRICK AND
MORTAR SOMEWHERE ELSE- I ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. I DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO PUT THIS THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN IT'S THE AB THIRTY ONE
STATEWIDE LOCAL PARK PROGRAM
THERE'S NO FUNDING IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THERE'S NO FUNDING THAT I COULD
SEE IN THE SENATE PROPOSAL. AND
THIS IS A PROBABLY THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL LOCAL PARK PROGRAM.
IN THE UNITED STATES IT HAS BEEN
AWARDED ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CREATED THREE HUNDRED
PARKS HAS BEEN RECEIVED EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
REQUEST- WE JUST TALKED TO THE
PART A COUPLE DAYS AGO. THEY
SAID THAT THEY HAVE SCORES OF
PARK PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO
BE FUNDED AND SCORED VERY WELL.
BUT THE LAST ROUND OF FUNDING
WHICH WAS THE LAST OF THE MONEY.
THE PROGRAM SIMPLY RAN OUT OF
MONEY AND THAT'S WHY THEY DIDN'T
GET AWARDED SO I'D REALLY LIKE
TO PASS THE SENATE TO TAKE A-
CLOSE LOOK AT THAT THIS PROGRAM
CHECKS EVERY SINGLE BOX.
IMAGINABLE FROM EQUITABLE ACCESS
EXTREME HEAT INTERVENTION OF
FLOOD MEDICATION OF HUMAN AND
MENTAL HEALTH- YOU KNOW COVERT
LAID BARE HOW IMPORTANT LOCAL
PARKS ARE. SO I DON'T KNOW WHY
THAT PROGRAM DOES NOT HAVE ANY
FUNDING AND- LASTLY I'D WANT TO
TALK TO ABOUT GREEN SCHOOLYARDS-
CENTER WELL WHY CASKEY I. ALSO
QUESTIONED CAL FIRE BEING MANY
OF. OPERATOR OF THIS PROGRAM
WE'VE DONE TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOLYARDS IN NEW YORK CITY
FINISHED OVER TWENTY YEARS. AND
FIVE IN OAKLAND THREE OF WHICH
ARE FINISHED IN TO WILL BE BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR. THEY'RE
ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS EACH
TO DO AND WE LOOK AT THEM AS
PART PROJECTS SO THAT WE CAN PUT
PERMEABLE SURFACES. CAPTURE
WHATEVER STORMWATER THAT HITS
THE GROUND WHICH WHICH
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO DO WE CAN'T
SQUANDER ANY WATER. ANYWHERE IN
THE STATE AND WE OF COURSE HAVE
TREE CANOPIED MODERN. PLAY
EQUIPMENT WE LOOK WE ARE PARK
DEVELOPERS THAT'S THE WAY WE
LOOK AT SCHOOL CAMPUSES. YOU
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE STUDENTS
THE FACULTY THE BOARD OF THIS IS
NOT A SINGLE WHATEVER WE DO IF
WE PICK ONE IT EXISTING PROGRAM
IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW. IT'S A
SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND HOLE WE
NEED A ONE STOP SHOPPING FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
GREEN THEIR SCHOOLYARDS- THAT
COULD BE REPRESENTED BY MULTI
AGENCIES LIKE US G. C. DOES. BUT
HAS THE ABILITY. TO COVER
EVERYTHING THAT'S NEEDED BECAUSE
WHEN WE DO SCHOOLYARDS IN
OAKLAND WE HAVE TO STITCH
TOGETHER GRANTS FROM EIGHT
DIFFERENT PLACES. AND THEN HOPE
TO GOD THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS WILLING TO DO A JOINT USE
AGREEMENTS OF THE COMMISSION IF
YOU CAN USE THAT AFTER SCHOOL
HOURS. SO OFTEN THERE I'D BE
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
YOUR STAFF AND- BUT THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NECKS. GOOD AFTERNOON
ELENA ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
SEE ACTION FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS BCP AND
ACCOMPANYING BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. REGARDING THE
PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR DPR IN
THE INTERNET. ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE TO INVESTIGATE AND
DEVELOP PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT
CASES TO REACTIVATE DPR
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS. AND TO
ADOPT A LONG OVERDUE INCREASE IN
THE MAXIMUM PENALTIES FOR
PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS AND
PESTICIDE SALES AND LICENSING
VIOLATIONS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FINDING NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS PROPOSAL. WHICH
WILL PROVIDE FIFTY TWO MILLION
FOR CERTIFIED LOCAL CORES AND
TRIBAL CONSERVATION CORPS
PROGRAMS THIS FUNDING WILL GO TO
THE CCC OVER TWO YEARS AND WILL
ENSURE CRITICAL RESOURCES FOR
LOCAL COURTS ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. OF CLIMATE LEADERS
WHILE ALSO CARRYING OUT
DESPERATELY NEEDED NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PROJECTS IN OR
COMMUNITIES AS NOTED THE B. C.
P. IN THE B. C. PETE LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE HAVE A DEEP
HISTORY OF. DELIVERING
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC INEQUITY
OUTCOMES THROUGH NATURE BASED
SOLUTION PROJECTS WHICH CAN
RANGE FROM NATURAL HABITAT
RESTORATION TO TREE PLANTING IN
COMMUNITY GREENING TO DEVELOPING
AND CONSTRUCTING PARKS WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN COUNT ON THE SENATE
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM. AS
DEPLOYING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE
IS GOING TO BE AN ESSENTIAL
SOLUTION AND MEETING OUR STATE
WHAT CLAVICLES THANK YOU. WITH
HELLO ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
SEMPERVIRENS FUND MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
THE LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. ARE DISCUSSING AS WELL
THE NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS BCP
FROM THE RESOURCES AGENCY WE ARE
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE FULL
B. C. P. AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LEADERSHIP AND
PUTTING IT TOGETHER. WE TRULY
BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO HELPING US REACH THE GOAL OF
CONSERVING 30% OF LANDS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. I AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL WHEN
THE TIME COMES THANK YOU. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WHAT CUTS
CAN MEMBERS- STEVEN MYERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
- THE COALITION ADMINISTERS
STATE AUTHORIZED NATURAL
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANS AND
FEDERALLY AUTHORIZED HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANS WHICH ARE KEY
PARTNERS IN THE STATE'S EFFORTS
TO PROTECT AND RESTORE CRITICAL
HABITATS. IN AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE UNDER IMMENSE PRESSURE
TO DEVELOP PLANT. A FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PRESERVES
WILL ENSURE THAT WILDLIFE WILL
BE ABLE TO SURVIVE IN THE FACE
OF A CHANGING CLIMATE AND WILL
HAVE THE WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
NECESARY TO FIND. ADEQUATE
HABITAT IN THE FUTURE SO WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO CDFW FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF IN CCPS NXC
PEAS. IN THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PACKAGE AND WE URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENT WHEN IT IS BEFORE YOU
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Q. MODERATOR- THAT CONCLUDES THE
HEARING ARE THE TESTIMONY HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
EUROPE THIS TIME DID NOT PRESS
ONE ZERO SECOND TIME AT THAT
WILL REMOVE YOU FROM THE
COMMENTS KILL. WE'RE GOING TO GO
FIRST LINE THIRTY. ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
LIKE HEALTHCARE- THIS IS KIM
DELFINO- ON THE HAPLESS
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AUDUBON
AND NORMALLY I'M TRUST- SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO ITEM FOURTEEN I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THE COMPLETION OF
THE TWO STRATEGIES BY THE
RESOURCES AGENCY. WITH RESPECT
TO FUNDING FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY
WERE PLEASED TO SEE THE MONEY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
DIRECTED TOWARDS W. C. B.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE CONSERVANCY'S
AND URBAN GREENING AND URBAN
FORESTRY PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
TRIBAL OF PROGRAM AND-
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION CLIMATE
SMART LAND MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
HOWEVER I THINK AS YOU NOTED- WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
AUGMENTATION FOR THAT IN THE
SENATE CLIMATE PROPOSAL AND WE
WOULD URGE THAT ANY FINAL
PROPOSAL COMING OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT IS BEEFED
UP TO REFLECT THOSE MORE ROBUST
FUNDING NUMBERS. WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY- WE WOULD
NOTE THOUGH THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR CAPACITY BUILDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NGOS PLAN TRUST IN OUR SEATS
WILL BE TASKED WITH CARRYING OUT
A LOT OF THE WORK IS FIFTY WITH
THIRTY BY THIRTY. AND WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT LIKE WITH THE
FUNDING DIRECTED- INTO SCIENCE
AND DATA IN ADDITION TO WHAT
READY THEM CLOSE CLOSE FROM CAL
NATURE IN PARTICULAR WE BELIEVE
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO COMPLETE
MAPPING THE REMAINING 40% OF THE
STATE. FIND SKILLED VEGETATION
MAPPING SO THAT IT CAN INDEED
IDENTIFY THE MOST IMPORTANT
AREAS BIODIVERSITY- THANK FOUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY WITHOUT THAT
DATA WORK ACTUALLY FLYING IN THE
DARK IN THOSE 40% OF THE STATE
WHICH IS THE CENTRAL COAST
HEARING ABOUT US. THANK ARE WITH
THAT JUST A YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION FEEDBACK. THANK YOU.
BY FORTY. GOOD SIR WHAT OF
SCHEME MEMBERS OF THE CAN THAT
ALL MASON WITH PACIFIC TRUST AND
I CAN THINK OF TIME BY EVERY CAN
DELFINO JUST SAID WHICH COVER
ABOUT 80% OF MY COMMENTS WERE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF SEEING THE
ALLOCATION PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS BUT AS IT TURNED OUT
THAT IS NOWHERE NEAR THE NEEDS
AND WILL STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE PROPOSAL TO ROUND THAT UP
SUBSTANTIALLY. I WOULD ALSO
REALLY HIGHLIGHT THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL TO MAKE A ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN WATERSHED RESILIENCE THAT'S
ANOTHER REALLY KEY ELEMENT OF
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AND
ENHANCING THE SECURITY AND
RELIABILITY OF OUR WATER SUPPLY
BY IMPROVING THE TIMING OF RUN
OFF AND- BUT THE FIRE BEHAVIOR
IN THE WATERSHED SO THANK YOU
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
IN WRITING. THANK YOU NECK. LINE
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARDMEMBERS DAILY RUSSIAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE'RE
PROVIDING COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN- I'D LIKE TO BE SURE
THAT THE PROPER CONTEXT AROUND
THIS PROPOSAL POVIDED
AGRICULTURE HAS A 99% COMPLIANCE
RATE WITH PESTICIDE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE CONTINUALLY AND
OVERWHELMINGLY TESTS WITHIN
RESIDUE LIMITS SO UNFORTUNATELY
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS A RESPONDING TO
ALLEGED THE MEN AND EVIDENCE
BASED NEED FOR INCREASED USE
pLIKE TO HAVE SOME TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- STAFF AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD REGULATION TO
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR PRACTICAL
CONCERNS AROUND THE PROPOSAL FOR
RESIDUE TESTING- AND ALLOW FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR MINOR
UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MAX LINE TWENTY
EIGHT. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
MIND IS NOW OPEN. IF YOU SHARE
MEMBER MAYBE LOUIS BROWN TO TAKE
CALL ON BEHALF OF CALVIN CAUGH
. WESTRAC PROSTATE. CAL YEAH
YOU'RE THOSE. THE LINE MIGHT
COME WITH A ROW. CALIFORNIA
BUREAU. ALSO ADD THAT HOW DO YOU
QUESTION THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
STAFF BASED ON THE COMPLIANCE
RECORDS THAT DESTRUCTION DATE
AT. LEAST IN MY EXPERIENCE STAFF
ARE RARELY CAMPER SO WILD
PROPOSED EACH THREE YEARS. FULLY
EXPECTED TO BE A MINUTE SOMETIME
THE TRANSITION TO THE BILL FUND-
WHICH IS PAID BY MY CLIENTS AND
OTHERS ALSO A RATE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE INFLATIONARY INCREASE.
IN THE PROPOSAL WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TIME FOR
FEES BE INCREASE BASED ON
INFLATION BECAUSE THEY ARE IN IT
ACOSTA PROGRAM DON'T THINK THAT
THAT ARE SAYING RIGHT NOW FIVE
IF YU FIND. THAT SHOULD BE MORE
IN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE THOSE FIND
THE APPROPRIATE MAXWELL FIND.
OUT FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE
AND SO. THE DAY BEFORE. NEXT WHY
FORTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE TO AND ARE DAM CIVIL
BURKE WITH IN GAME CAPITA WITH
IS CERTAIN CAL REGION CONTRA
CORPS. ON ON ITEMS FOR MAJOR
BASIL. WHICH SUPPORT. THE SENATE
AUGMENT. A PARTICULAR COULD BY
THIRTY FIVE S. WHAT KIND
CONSCIOUS OF LAPTOP- I TO SAY
THAT. GOOD IS THAT WE NEED TO BE
ANNUALLY FOR LAND ACQUISITION
FOR NUMBER IF YOU. SO GETTING A
CLOSE THE AS PART TO THEM IS
REALLY IN THIS. I'D ALSO LIKE
SPEAK FAVOR OF THE WATER
CONSERVATION. CORRECT YEAH. OF
THIS SCOPE- HAS A GREAT TRACK
RECORD OF. ALL SORTS OF
INVESTMENTS IN ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE BENEFITING MULTIPLE
CONSTITUENCIES AND IT'S READY TO
GO IT JUST MEANS MONEY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NECKS LINE. FIFTY
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KILL ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION AND ENERGY ACTION FUND
BEGAN ITEM THIRTEEN BE EXTREMELY
ACT BUT IT SHOULD BE PACKAGE OR
IN SUPPORT OF- ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION PROPOSED FOR
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS OF
A GREAT STAFF TOWARDS FUNDING
OUR LARGER REQUEST FOR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO CONSTRUCT AN
UPGRADE COMMUNITY EVENTS CENTER
LIKE COOL LIBRARIES AND OTHER
PUBLIC BUILDINGS. WE'D ALSO LIKE
TO ECHO SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
TODAY ON HOW THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THE COVERAGE
BUDGET FOR EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION I'M HOPING
AFFORDABLE AND ADDRESSING
EXTREME HEAT AND HOME AND ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT FUNDING-
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS BUDGET. THANK YOU NEXT.
LINE FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN COMMITTEE MEMBERS HOW
MEDARY CALLING ON BEHALF THE
WEST MEMBERS I COUNTY REGIONAL
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FOURTEEN WHICH
IS REPRESENTED SUPPORT LETTER
FOR THE SENATE CLIMATE PACKAGE
SUBMITTED ON MONDAY ANDERSON IS
CORRECT. THAT WHERE WE CONSERVE
LAND MATTERS THE PATH WITH A
THIRTY BY THIRTY DOCUMENT
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE OF HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANS AND NATIONAL
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANTS AS
TOOLS QUICKLY BOLSTER OUR
BIODIVERSITY THE VC PETER PUZZLE
TO DIRECT THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO CDFW FOR ANTI P. AND
HTTP IMPLEMENTATION IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN OUR IT
HAS DONE A WONDERFUL JOB IN
DEVELOPING THE PATH WITH THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY HCV THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES ARE READY TO GO
WE JUST. THE ACQUISITION FUNDING
THANK YOU. THAT LINE FORTY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS CHERYL AND
ASHLEY IN THE HISTORIC
PRESERVATION DEPARTMENT OF THE
UNITED AUBURN INDIAN COMMUNITY
AND I WANTED TO SPEAK TO ITEM
FOURTEEN I'M NOT ONE TO SPEAK TO
THE TROUBLES INSIDE IN THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AND
THIRTY BY THIRTY AS LONG AS THE
CAPACITY BUILDING AND THIRTY BY
THIRTY. IS WANTED TO ADDRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THOSE
FUNDING FOR TRAVEL PROGRAM AND
KIND OF SPEAK ALSO TO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE ASKED EARLIER
ON ON HOW THOSE- TRIBAL
CONSERVATION CORPS PROGRAM MIGHT
LOOK DIFFERENT AND THAT WOULD BE
AND THE PRIORITIES AND APPROACH
TO THE WORK TRIBES MIGHT HAVE
DIFFERENT. OBJECTIVES THEY MIGHT
HAVE DIFFERENT TECHNIQUES AND
THEY MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT VALUES
AND HAVING PROBABLY LED
CONVERSATIONS AND HEAVILY LED
CREW CAN HELP- INCREASE THE
EQUITY WITH TRIED TO BUY- HAVING
TROUBLE LED OBJECTED ON THE WORK
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE FOURTH
REPORT THE NEW PROJECT- I ALSO
WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE CAPACITY
BUILDING AND. BECAUSE TRY THIS
ON PROJECTS ARE WORKING MOSTLY
SMALLER HE'S AN AGENT. AND IN
ORDER TO ENGAGE TRIED IN THE
PROJECT. THEY NEED TO INCREASE
THEIR COULD. AND THEN TRAVELER
IN IN THAT WAY TO WORK CLOSER TO
THEIR HOMES AND- BRING INTO
THEIR VALUES. INTO THOSE LOCAL
PROJECT THEY ALSO WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
FUNDING AND BOTH OF THOSE AREAS
FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NECKS. LINE. TWENTY NINE. WHY
TWENTY NINE OPEN. YES HELLO ARE
ABLE TO HEAR WHITE HOUSE YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ROB MOORE AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE THE
CONSERVATION CORPS. WE SERVICE
PARKS TRAILS AND OPEN STATE
SENATE DISTRICTS TEN THIRTEEN.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY. I'M HERE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR'S OFFCE AND
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY FOR THEIR BCP FOR AND
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. WITH THE
PIGGLY GRATEFUL THE PROPOSED
LOCAL AND TRIBAL. NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS CORE S. U. D. C. I
WORK WITH CORPS MEMBERS IN
PROGRAMS LIKE OUR TRAIL SAFETY
TEAM FOR YOUNG ADULTS. HELP OUR
COMMUNITY BY CLEANING UP AND
FIXING TRAIL HAZARDS REPORTING
AN APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES ON THE
TRAIL TO AUTHORITIES. AND IF THE
THING FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS.
ON THE TRAIL WITH ANY
INFORMATION THEY NEED. THE
FUNDING AND BY. TO GROW
IMPORTANT LIKE THIS RUN THEM TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN ACHIEVE TOGETHER
IN OUR COLLECTIVE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU ALL FOR
EVERYTHING YOU DO AND FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. NEXT LINE. THIRTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERMAN WAY CASKEY AND RICHARD
WHAT ARE HERE WITH CLIMATE
RESULT NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN
LOS ANGELES WORKING TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF EXTREME
HEAT LET'S SPEAK ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SUBSTANTIAL AND ONGOING FUNDING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH FOR THE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE AND EXTREME
HEAT PROGRAM. ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR S. B. ONE FIVE FIVE HERE'S
WHAT. FIRST THE PROPOSAL BUT IT
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING FACTORS CONTRIBUTING
TO THE MOST PRESSING
VULNERABILITY AFFECTING THE
ENTIRE STATE. THE DAILY THREATS
OF EXTREME HEAT. SECOND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS NEEDED TO
PREVENT DEATHS AND PREPARE FOR
THE PREDICTED INCREASE IN HEAT
WAVES AND POWER OUTAGES. LASTLY
THERE'S A DIRE NEED TO FUND
COORDINATED ADAPTATION
STRATEGIES LIKE COOPER HEATING
COOL ROOFS NATURAL AND
MECHANICAL SHEET. PASSIVE
EVAPORATIVE COOLING AND MANY
MANY OTHER STRATEGIES THAT HAVE
PROVEN EFFECTIVE AND THAT REDUCE
THE URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT.
WHICH OVER HERE STREETS AND
BUILDINGS RESULTING IN
PREVENTABLE FATALITIES. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
EXTREME HEAT IS EXACERBATING
IMPACTS ON VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
OF THE SENATE TO CONSIDER
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL DELIVER
IMMEDIATE RELIEF. AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUBSTANTIAL
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND EXTREME HEAT
PROGRAM. ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR
SB. ONE FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. THE
EX. LINE. FIFTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BELINDA
FILIPINOS AND I'M A STRATEGIC
ADVISOR WITH ELLIE WATERKEEPER
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STATE
WIDE THIRTY BY THIRTY EQUITY
COALITION- AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF THAT THAT
PARTICULAR CONVENIENCE AND
COALITION OFFERS ABOUT WE WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING UP THIS MATTER IN THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED
UNDER ITEM FOURTEEN ON YOUR
AGENDA TODAY HOWEVER AS
MENTIONED BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
IN ORDER TO REALLY ACHIEVE OUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS WE NEED
TO SEE AT LEAST A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR BOTH LAND
AND OCEAN CONSERVATION ALL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
REQUIRED THAT THE STATE
ACKNOWLEDGE. ATONE FOR AND-
DECONSTRUCT. AND OF THE
OPPRESSION. OF TO MAKE PROCESS
OF PROGRESS IN RESOLVING AND
RECONCILING HISTORIC LAND USE.
AND LAND MANAGEMENT TO RESTORE
NATURE FOR NATIVE CRIED. AND LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR.
ACHIEVING EQUITY WILL REQUIRE
DEDICATED RESOURCES OF AT LEAST
50% OF ALL FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR
THE THIRTY BY THIRTY PROGRAM.
DUE TO THIS HISTORIC
DISINVESTMENT. WE FURTHER
RECOMMEND THAT CAPACITY BUILDING
FOR COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THE
NATIVE TRIBES ARE IS ESSENTIAL.
THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
BUDGET THAT INCLUDED A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR NATIVE TRIBES AND A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS LAND TRUSTS.
ARE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS WITH AT LEAST 55% OF
THAT FUNDING. GOING TO COMMUNITY
BASED. ORGANIZATIONS AND TRIED.
LASTLY EQUITY MEANS NOT ONLY CAN
. EQUAL AND OPPORTUNITIES BUT
ALSO ADVOCATING FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND DEFINITION OF
EQUITY MUST INCLUDE THE FOR
EQUITY LENSES ACCESS
REPRESENTATION MEANINGFUL
PARTICIPATION AND QUALITY
EXPERIENCE AS AN OUTCOME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY THANK
YOU NEXT. LINE FIFTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS BRENDAN
WOLFE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR FURTHER- TO
FURTHER ITS FINAL THIRTY BY
THIRTY STRATEGY IN PARTICULAR WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING DIRECTED TO
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
STATE CONSERVANCIES- AND FOR
URBAN GREENING AND URBAN
FORESTRY WITH NATIVE PLANT
SPECIES WE SUPPORT THAT ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR TRIBAL
PARTNERSHIPS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THAT THE FINAL BUDGET INCLUDED
DECISIONAL FUNDING TO BRING THE
TOTAL TO ONE HUNDRED BILLION
ANNUALLY TOWARD REVISING THIRTY
BY THIRTY. WHICH IS FINE
PERMANENT PER. FOR IMPORTANT
PLANT AREAS AND TO ENSURE THAT-
FOR HALF OF THIS FUNDING IS
DIRECTED TOWARDS BIODIVERSITY
CONSERVATION ACTIONS IN CLIMB IN
FULL NOBLE COMMUNITIES WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
GREATER INVESTMENT IN CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR CBO'S NGOS LAND
TRUSTS AND RCTS. FINALLY WE
STRONGLY URGE THAT THE THERE IS
FUNDING TO DEVELOP SCIENCE AND
DATA FOR GOOD DECISION MAKING
INCLUDING FORTY MILLION FOR FINE
SCALE VEGETATION MAPPING TO
FINISH MAPPING THE REMAINING 40%
OF THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU NEXT. LINE FIFTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND
THE MELAMINE FOUNDATION WE JUST
WANT TO AND SUBSTRUCTURE STRONG
SUPPORT PARTICULARLY FOR THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FINAL ALLOTMENT
THE BILL ABILITY CANYON WILDLIFE
CROSSING IN SPECIAL THANKS TO
THE GOVERNOR AND A SENATOR STERN
FOR THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND JUST
VERY HAPPY TO BE THERE OUT- THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR
INCREASED COMMITMENT AND
MOMENTUM TOWARDS WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS AND CORRIDORS AND
SECONDLY ON BEHALF OF OPTIONAL
ARE GOING TO QUALITY CENTER WITH
REGARD TO THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE IN NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. WE ARE PLEASED AND
HOPEFUL ONE INDICATION OF THE
PROGRAM WILL ALLOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEAN ON BEAVERS-
MORE TO PROTECT AND BUILD
WATERSHED HEALTH. THANK YOU.
NEXT WHY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS THIS IS TASHA
NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS AND THAT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT WE'RE
SPEAKING ON ITEM FOURTEEN AND
WOULD LIKE TO LINE OUR COMMENTS
WITH KIM DELFINO AND DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO DISTRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INCREASED INVESTMENT AS PROPOSED
BY THE SENATE. AND ALSO THE
THREATS THE NEED FOR CAPACITY
FUNDING FOR LAND TRUST WITH OUR
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND OTHER
LOCAL PARTNERS THAT WILL HELP
THE STATE ACHIEVES THE GOALS AS
OUTLINED IN THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
THE CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MAX. LINE.
SEVEN ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR ONE
NOW OPEN. HELLO KAREN MEMBERS
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF THE L. A. RIVER
VALLEY NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
AND COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION.
ARE WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
RESOURCES AGENCY P. C. P. RICKLY
THE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STATE CONSERVANCY TO
CARRY OUT REGION SPECIFIC
CONSERVATION PROJECTS STATEWIDE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE TIME COMES THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY EIGHT.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR AND ESPECIALLY HARD
WORKING STAFF WHO MUST NEED MUCH
BY NOW I'M DAN WE CAN CAMP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BIODIVERSITY ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH GPL SCHOOLS ARE IN
EVERY COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE THE
UNCAPPED SOLUTION TO EXTREME
HEAT RESIIENCE WE NEED MORE NOW
WE CAN'T DO ENOUGH ON ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS WE RESTORING A COMET.
CAN DOCKING UP WE THANK THE
SENATE FOR YOUR RECENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO BE BALD AS YOU MOVE
TO REGAIN CALIFORNIA STATUS WITH
THE LEADER IN CRIME AND IT'S
ACTUALLY BY TO CONSERVATION
SPECIFICALLY WE APPLAUD THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THIRTY BY THIRTY- AND ACTUALLY
TO LEVERAGE THE GREAT TOOLS THAT
YOU ALREADY HAVE SUCH AS WATER
CONSERVATION BOARD IN THE OTHER
CONSERVANCY WHILE ALSO INVESTING
IN BUILDING NEW CAPACITY AND
ADVANCING EQUITY BY SUPPORTING
NONPROFIT CBO CONTRACTS. WILL BE
WORKED ON METRICS AND OUTCOMES
YES WE DEFINITELY NEED METRICS
BUT THESE ARE HARD TO CALCULATE
LARGELY BECAUSE SCIENTISTS STILL
DON'T HAVE THE MOST BASIC
BIODIVERSITY INFORMATION WE NEED
TO TAKE THAT FOLLOWING THE
BARBER STATE THERE'S JUST A LOT
TO MAP AND SO WE REQUEST THAT
YOU LISTEN TO ON THE GROUND SITE
STATE THAT THEY NEED HELP THEM
FOR EXAMPLE THE THIRTY BY THIRTY
THIS REPORT BASICALLY CALLS FOR
A ONE TIME EFFORT TO GET BASIC
DATA BY FINISHING OF EDUCATION
OPERA CALIFORNIA. SECURING OUR
BUYERS. THANK YOU. AND ALL TACK
BY THE BRIDGE INVENTORY SUCH A
THE PROPOSAL YET SO ABOUT RISK
DNA. UP THESE ARE TWO PART OF.
OUT FROM THE MINUTES. ABOUT YOUR
PROPOSAL. AND WE HOPE THAT YOU
DECIDE TO MAKE THAT THESE ARE
INCLUDED AS YOU RECALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK
IN YOUR IMAGE ACTION. REQUIRING
THANK YOU. NEXT LINE. ONE IS NOW. BUT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES- AHEAD
YOUR CLEANER HIGHER QUALITY. HI
CHAIR MEMBERS FINANCE THOMAS
MCMAHON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. ZACKS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS WILL BE THE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME IF YOU HAVE NOT SPOKEN
SO FAR.
MODERATOR OKAY THE MYSTERY OF UP
PARDON ME MISTER CHAIR JUST
MOMENT I APOLOGIZE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN PLACE. AND
WE HAVE ONE FINAL PERSON WHO'S
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF- THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CAMPUS
SECOND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT. CALDERON ON
SPEAKING TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SUPPORT INITIATION THIRTY BY
THIRTY FUNDING AND THE AUTHOR
ALIGNER COMMENTS THE
THANKSGIVING BY CONDUCTING I
THINK YOU'RE AWESOME. THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC
HEARING- AND I WILL MOVE TO OUR
OUR VOTES WE HAVE OR- CAN I HAVE
A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEMS ONE
INTO ITEMS FOUR THROUGH EIGHT
ITEMS TEN ELEVEN AND TWELVE AND
ITEM SIXTEEN. THERE'S A MOTION
BY CENTER STERN MISS ROY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MY CASKEY HI MY
CASKET CURRENTLY ONLY AND
REQUIRE. REQUIRE ICE STERN STERN
THREE ZERO. THREE HAS ANNOUNCED
THE VOTE AT THREE ZERO THE YOUTH
THOSE MEMBERS ARE PROVED THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS. OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE BUDGET DISCUSSIONS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE FIRST OFFICIAL
RECORDS TODAY THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND THANK YOU
FOR EVERY. ONE WHO TESTIFIED
HERE AND PERSON IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED TO THE GENDER FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO HIS INSURANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.